AND GET TODAY'S HEARING STARTED.
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ FROM
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INTO THESE
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY.
WHILE ALLOWING FOR FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TO
THEIR ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN WE
ARE HAVING TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AND MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC AND MEDIA WHO CAN KEEP
SIXTY THE SPACING. THEY'RE
AWFUL STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO TAKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I WILL RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAINST BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK THEY WILL
RAISE THEIR HANDS. NOW ASKING
TO PUT THE MICROPHONE. WILL
ALSO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE. WE'LL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE'VE HEARD ALL
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC RESPECT THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THEME AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. WE WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT THE PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL THIS NOTHING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
L. A. O. IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE PAYING REMOTELY
TODAY. I ASK THAT EVERYONE
SILENCE ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND
PLEASE BE YOURSELF WHEN YOU ARE
NOT SPEAKING. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN COMMITTEE TODAY.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
CDC ARE PRESSING CLOSER PLAN
LONG TERM FACILITY INVESTMENT
STRATEGY AND VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS. WE HAVE A GROWING
TWENTY BILLION LIST OF FACILITY
NEEDS INCLUDING CAPITAL OUTLAY
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IT'S
CLEAR THAT MOST OF THE PERSONS
ARE IN DIRE NEED OF REPAIR AND
MODERNIZATION FOR THE SAFETY OF
ALL THE STAFF AND THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. MANY OTHER
PRISONS WERE BUILT MORE THAN
FORTY TO FIFTY YEARS AGO. WHEN
THEY WERE CONSTRUCTED.
REVOCATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PRIORITIES WERE NOT CRITICAL
FACTORS THE FOCUS IS PRIMARILY
ON SECURITY. AND SECURITY ONLY.
AND THEY COULD LATER WE KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND SUBSTANCE
USE ORDER THIS SORT OF
TREATMENT IN ADDITION TO THE
KERRY. IN OUR PRISONS WERE NOT
BUILT TO PROTECT STAFF OR
PRISONERS AGAINST INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. THE CURRENT REDUCTION
OUR PRISON POPULATION WHICH IS
FEWER THAN NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE THE LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN
THREE DECADES ALSO PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
TRULY FOCUS AND LEVERAGE ITS
INVESTMENTS DURING. A LONG AT
IN A DURABLE LONG TERM
FACILITIES. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
pCDC ARE FOR SEVERAL YEARS LAST
WEEK THE DEPARTMENT HAS.
INDICATED IT WILL BE SUBMITTING
A PROPOSAL FOR CONSIDERATION
WHICH WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR JOINING OUR
HEARING. I LOOK FORWARD TO
TODAY'S DISCUSSIONS. PANELISTS
PLEASE HE REPRESENTATIVES BRIEF
SO THAT WE HAVE THE VISION
SEVERAL QUESTIONS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. AFTER
EACH PANEL I WILL OPEN UP FOR
THE SUB COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
ASK QUESTIONS. OUR FIRST ISSUE.
PERCENT OF CLOSER A LONG TERM
FACILITY INVESTMENT PLAN. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
ISSUE AND WE'LL HAVE THE PANEL
SPEAK IN THE ORDER LISTED IN
THE AGENDA WHEN YOU DO SPEAK
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE CAN BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS DEAN
MORGAN AND I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MANAGEMENT
DIVISION- WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE ONE AND
THE OTHER ISSUES ON THE AGENDA
THIS AFTERNOON- AS- A AS
MENTIONED. THERE WAS A SIMPLE
LITTLE REPORT LANGUAGE- THAT
WAS INCLUDED WITH THE- TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET UP FROM LAST YEAR
THAT REQUESTED THE DEPARTMENT
TO OPERATE A PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE RECRUITMENT
STRATEGY. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. MEET WITH. THE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
ANDERSON SENATE COLLEAGUES-
LAST WEEK TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER. I AM RESPONSIBLE
MEETING- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING THE PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE- IMPROVEMENT
STRATEGY THAT WAS REQUESTED
THROUGH THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE. AND BEING ABLE TO
MEET THE DEADLINE OF THE
SUPPLEMENT REPORT LANGUAGE-
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THIS
REPORT WILL I BE ABLE TO LOOK
BEYOND THE FIVE YEAR TIME FRAME
THAT I HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED. WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PERFORM- TEN YEAR A LOOK AT OUR
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AS
IS REQUESTED IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL LANGUAGE- ONE OF
THE REPORT. WILL ALSO INCLUDE
NARRATIVE TO DESCRIBE HOW.
WOULD PLAN TO PROVIDE A
THOROUGH AND FLEXIBLE. ALL
PRESENT THIS. ARE LOOKING AT
TEN AND THE FUTURE. SO I HAVE
AS MENTIONED- WE ARE ON SOME.
THAT OUR PARTICULAR. OF THE
REPORT AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
SHARING THAT. WITH THE-I
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE OTHER
A. O. FIRST WEEK OF MARCH AND-
CAN TO THEIR- FROM THAT POINT.
FOR HERE'S IN MAKING PRISON
CLOSURE- DECISIONS. AND OTHER
BUNDLES THERE SIX ITEMS
SPECIFICALLY LISTED IN THAT
REPORT IT INCLUDED THE COST
OPERATE AT THE FACILITY
WORKFORCE IMPACTS THE STAFF-
SOME POPULATION AND GENDER
SPECIFIC HOUSING NEEDS.
DURABILITY OF STATE SOLUTION
OVERCROWDING PUBLIC SAFETY
RECALL PATIENT AND A FINAL ITEM
BESIDES THOSE FIVE I'M LOOKING
AT LONG TERM INVESTMENT AND-
INCLUDING PREVIOUS INVESTMENTS
IN THOSE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. SO DURING OUR
TWENTY TWENTY THE DEPARTMENT
USE THE THAT THOSE GUIDELINES
CRITERIA EVALUATED- THOSE
FACTORS FOR WRITING PERSONS.
AND IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ANNOUNCED THAT THAT THEY DO
WILL OCCASIONAL INSTITUTION
NEAR TRACY WOULD BE CLOTHING
AND THE CLOSURE DATE IS SET FOR
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF THIS YEAR. MY
COLLEAGUE ACTUALLY GOT THE
WARDEN INVESTED SOME OF HIS
LEADING CDCR SEPARATES RELATED
TO THIS CLOSURE AND HELP
PROVIDE BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT
THE SAVINGS THAT WILL BE
GENERATED BY THE CLOSURE. AND
THE CURRENT ACTIVITY. PLANNING
FOR DVRS CLOVER. YEAH ADVANCED
FROM SILOS CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
CHRISTIAN SHE KEPT WATER- AND
SHE OF THE MEMBER. SO AT YOU.
GONNA GO EIGHTEEN. THAT
APARTMENT I WENT ON A PRETTY
EXTENSIVE- SORRY. BOB WE
INITIATED. REDUCING THE PRISON
POPULATION OUT OF STATE SO ALL
OF THAT OF THE PRISON
POPULATION WAS BROUGHT BACK TO
CALIFORNIA WE NOW CLOSE ALL
PRIVATE LEE CONTRACTED IN STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES WILL
CLOSE TWO OUT OF THREE PUBLIC
CONTRACTED CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AND STATE WITH THE
THIRD PLAN ON A CLOSURE IN MAY
SO WITH THE NATURAL PROGRESSION
PERCENT A LOT EIGHTEEN WE
DESIGNATED OKAY SUBSTITUTION AS
THE FIRST INSTITUTION OF
CLOTHES- WE NOW SEPTEMBER. IT'S
ON TRACK RIGHT NOW TO CLOSE
SEPTEMBER. THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ON- THERE'S- SAVINGS A
HUNDRED FOR MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
WITH ADDITIONAL SAVINGS OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE HAD
OVER NINE HUNDRED SEVEN FIVE
POSITIONS WILL BE REDUCED AS
PART OF THIS CLOSURE. ARE
CURRENTLY THERE'S ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED INMATES AT THE LOCATION
STATION THAT WILL REQUIRE
TRANSFER SO THE IN. HE DIDN'T
INSTITUTION IS ACTIVELY. THE
TRANSFER THOSE INMATES WE ARE
TRYING TO RESCHEDULE ALREADY
PLANNED OUT. IT'S GOING TO
START UP WILL GRADUALLY AND
THAT'LL SPEED UP THROUGH THE
SPRING MONTHS ALREADY THE
SUMMER. AND WE BELIEVE WE'RE ON
TRACK FOR THAT. THAT'S SMALL
REDUCTION AGREEMENT POPULATION
ACTUALLY THE CLOSURE. I DON'T.
SO ALSO THERE ARE AT CHANGE
FROM INMATES WILL GET CARDS
WITH THE CODE CAUTIONS THAT
THOSE THERE'S A PRETTY FOURTEEN
PRE TRANSFER ARE G. ISOLATION
OF THE TEST EIGHTY NINE THAT'S
WHERE THE TRANSFER- THAT HR
PROCESS ARE UNDERWAY THE UNIONS
HAVE BEEN NOTICED WE'VE ENGAGED
WITH COUNTY CHAR AND THE UNIONS
WE'VE ENGAGED ON OUR- INITIAL
NEGOTIATIONS- WE'VE PROPOSED A
VOLUNTARY TRANSFER PROCESS. TO
HELP MITIGATE THE IMPACT ON THE
IN THE INSTITUTION STAB WOUNDS
SO ARE JANET TRY TO REDUCE OUR
STAFF WILL BE IMPACTED DURING
THE LAYOUT PROCESS- IN THE
PARKING THAT CAN HAPPEN WITHIN
COUNTY. SO WE'RE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE SHE'S WITH THE UNION
REGARDING THAT- WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED. A HIGH
RESTRICTIONS STATE. THE HELP
LOCATE AND LOOK FOR TO BE
PLACED OUT- INCLUDING THE
REGIONAL AREA A SIGNIFICANT HI
RESTRICTION GUNS BEEN AFFECT
FOR QUITE SOMETIME TRY TO OPEN
UP THE AREA WITHIN ABOUT NINETY
MILE RADIUS OF THE END OF OUR
NEW LOCATIONS DIVISION. AND
THERE ARE TEN STATIONS UP ALL
WITHIN THAT RADIUS WHICH GIVES
US A LOT OF ROOM FOR STAFF
PLACEMENTS WHICH TO HELP
MITIGATE THE IMPACT AND IF
THERE ARE ANY LAOS. IT'LL BE
REDUCED SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE- I
MYSELF FOR WORKING KIDS. AND
THAT'S ONLY MANAGEMENT. WHAT
WE'RE NEEDING TO ACTUAL
INSTITUTION CALL YOUR
EVERYTHING FROM DISPOSAL AND
TRANSFER I'M A QUICK MAN- THE-
GERMANS ARE BEING REGION'S.
WELL WE'RE- GONNA GIVE NOTICE
TO THE CAN A LIVE STAGE HOUSING
THERE'S ON A HOUSING OKAY SO
FROM THE WHOLE INSTITUTIONS AND
THE OLDER INSTITUTIONS HAVE ON
STATE HOUSING WE HAVE TO GIVE
NOTICE IS TENANTS- AND THEN
EVENTUALLY I WILL WOK OUR WAY
DOWN CLOSING HOUSING UNITS AND
FACILITATING. THE CLOSURE. I'M
NOT. THAT'S RIGHT OR THE COVER.
THANK THE CALL YOU WILL THANK
YOU. BUT IS THE VERY BRIEF
THERE TO MORE I- AND ISSUE ONE
THAT I'D LIKE MAKE A FEW ON- IN
ADDITION TO THE CLOSURE OF PART
PART OF THE CULTURAL OR IDLE
ISSUE INSTITUTION THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTING- WARM
SHUT DOWN RESOURCES- IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR WOULD BE ONE POINT
SIX MILLION. YOUR IMPACT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
IS TWO POINT TWO MILLION. THIS
FUNDING. FUNDING FOR A 12-1 A-
BE WISE AT DVR. LITTLE SHUT
DOWN PROGRAM A DVR SIMILAR TO
THE WARM SHUT DOWN THE WE
PERFORM A DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE FACILITIES THAT WOULD
CLOSE OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS-
THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE A VERY
SMALL STAFF. THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT- ON THE AIR HANDLING UNITS
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
LIKE THAT REMAIN OPERATIONAL.
MAINTAINS THE VALUE OF THE
ASSET FOR FUTURE DISPOSITION-
SMALLER PRODUCTS WILL BE TAKEN
CARE OF- DV I ALSO HAS  VERY
LARGE AMOUNT OF BROWN'S SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE KEEP
OUR WEED ABATEMENT AND OTHER
THINGS- IN CONTROL THERE- WILL
HAVE A CONTRACTED SECURITY
SERVICE TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
OFF HOURS IT'S NOT ON ANY DAY-
CORRECTIVE ON TOP AND IT
PROACTIVE FOR VANDALISM- AND
LIKE I SAID THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH OTHER
CLOSURES THAT APARTMENT IS
DONE. OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS I
WILL ALSO BE WORKING ON THE
PART OF THE GENERAL SERVICES
THE PLANNING FOR THE EVENTUAL
SALE OR TRANSFER OF THE
PROPERTY- WHAT ARE EXPERIENCING
WELL NOW WITH THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROPERTIES. IS
THAT FINAL SAILOR TRANSFER CAN
TAKE SOME TIME- IN DURING THAT
PERIOD OF TIME CDCR REMAINS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LOCATION SO
AS I MENTIONED THE SECURITY
MANAGING WE GROWTH. AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE DON'T PROVIDING A
NEW SENSE OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY THAT'S A WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING THESE RESOURCES FOR-
ALSO NOTETHAT PTI HAS FIVE
TIMES THE BUILDING SQUARE
FOOTAGE ATTHE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY.
AND SIX TIMES THE EIGHT IT ALSO
WATER AND WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANT. SO I COMPARISON TO THE
AMOUNT OF- WARM SHUTDOWN
STAFFING THAT THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. FACILITY IS. NOT
EXACTLY APPLES TO APPLES. IN
THE ABSENCE OF I. HER MAKE THIS
BRIEF- ONE FINAL ITEM S. DO
WITH THE ACT THE- PROPOSED
REQUEST. FOR SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION OR SO. HEALTHCARE HAVE
BECOME READ. CENTER DOWN IN
NORTH- THE IS BECAUSE IT NO.
LARGE SCALE HEALTHCARE. IN
PROJECT THERE WAS DONE IN
NORTON NEW CAN- THERE. SO THAT.
PARTNERED WITH. S. AND IN PART.
UNDER THE RISKY OFFICE AND- CAL.
PERSONAL HEALTH CARE. TO
IDENTIFY A LOT OF REPAIRS TO
THE EXISTING HEALTHCARE SPACES.
WILL HELP IMPROVE HEALTHCARE IN
GENERAL MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
INFECTION CONTROL AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE- OF FACTORS. THESE
REPAIRS WILL OCCUR ON A PHASED
BASIS. WITH SEGMENTS WAITING
FOR OCT TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND.
BEING FULLY COMPLETED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE ANALYSIS
RAISE THE QUESTION OF WHY WE
WOULD PROPOSAL. FOR C. R. C.
WHEN I A POSSIBILITY THAT IT
MAY CLOSE AND SERVE ANOTHER
CLOSURE CAN BE ANNOUNCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. WE FEEL THAT'S
IMPORTANT REVIEW THE
REQUIREMENTS OF PEOPLE CO TWO
OH SIX SEVEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. IN A LOOK AT THIS
REPORT THROUGH THE LENS OF A
REASONS WHY A PERSON MAY BE
LIKELY TO REMAIN OPEN RATHER
THAN JUST LOOKING AT IT AS A
REASON WHY A PERSON MIGHT BE
LIKELY TO CLOSE. THE CRC
FACILITIES IN A RELOCATION.
THAT MAKES A GOOD FOR
VISITATION OF THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION IT MAKES IT
EXCELLENT FOR RECRUITING AND
THAT'S FOR ALL TYPES OF STAFF
PERSONAL STAFF AND HEALTHCARE
STAFF. WILL WORK NUMBER OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AT CRC
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
COLLEGE PROGRAMS. THESE ARE THE
FACTORS THAT HELP WAS MEASURE
OF THE SUCCESS OF SEASHORE'S
MISSION THAT ANY ONE OF OUR
PRISONS- STAFF AND- PARTNERS TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE. AND
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES IN
ORDER TO HELP INCARCERATED PROF
POPULATION PREPARE OR RETURN TO
SOCIETY. IF THE PRESIDENT MEETS
THIS CRITERIA THEN IF THEY'RE
GONNA BE STRONG CONSIDERATION
FOR THE PRISONS STATE OPEN WHEN
COMPARED TO OTHER REASONS WHY
IT MIGHT BE CNSIDERED FOR
CLOSURE. SO THOSE ARE THE
REASONS WHY TO BE HONEST THE
APARTMENT IS PUT FORWARD THE
REQUEST. FOR HEALTHCARE YOU CAN
CRC- NO IT WAS TALKING FAST-
BUT DON'T WANT TO GET THROUGH A
LOT OF THAT ISSUE. WE
APPRECIATE THE LINE AND WE'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THE COMMITTEE HAVE
FROM. THANK YOU FOR THE
APARTMENT OF MY- FIVE ANYTHING
TO. ADMISSION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. WHAT ABOUT
THE L. A. O.'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS CAITLIN
O'NEILL THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE DO HAVE
COMMENTS ON THE THREE ITEMS
WITH IT- THREE ITEMS WITHIN
THIS ISSUE I'LL START WITH THE
CLOSURE OF DV I HAVE ARE WE
HAVE THREE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THAT TOPIC. THE FIRST IS THAT
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION ON
THE BUDGET ADJUSTMENT RELATED
TO THE CLOSURE GIVEN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO ADJUST
THAT ESTIMATE AT THE ME REVISED
WHEN IT HAS MORE INFORMATION AT
THAT TIME. A SECOND WE THINK
THAT THE TWELVE POSITIONS
REQUESTED TO SUPPORT THE
WEREN'T SHUT DOWN OF THE
FACILITY APPEAR EXCESSIVE.
GIVEN THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY USES ONLY TWO
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE WARM
SHUT DOWN OF ANOTHER PERSON
THAT'S CURRENTLY CLOSED-
WELCOME KNOWLEDGE THAT DVI IS A
LARGER FACILITY- AND WOULD
PROBABLY NEED MORE THAN TWO
RESOURCES. ARE TWO POSITIONS.
FOR ITS MORE SHUT DOWN THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
JUSTIFY THE FULL TWELVE
POSITIONS IN OTHER WORDS WHY IT
NEEDS A FULL SIX TIMES- WHAT IT
USES TO SUPPORT ANOTHER PERSON.
WE THINK FIVE POSITIONS WOULD
BE REASONABLE SO WE RECOMMEND.
REJECT SEVEN POSITIONS- WHICH
WOULD REDUCE THE REQUEST BY
EIGHT SIX HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. THIRD THE
ULTIMATE DISPOSITION OF DV I
AND THE SECOND POSITION AT
PRESENT NOT SCHEDULE SCHEDULED
FOR CLOSURE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE IT'S UNCLEAR AT
THIS TIME SO IT'S NOT CLEAR IF
THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE WILL SELL
THOSE FACILITIES. AND THEREFORE
ELIMINATING THE NEED TO FUND
THE WARM SHUT DOWN OR SELL
CONTINUE TO BE A STATE NEED FOR
THEM SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT. BY
JANUARY TENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND WHAT OPTIONS IT'S
CONSIDERING FOR THE ALTERNATIVE
DISPOSITION OF THOSE PRISONS-
WE THINK THAT THEY'RE DOING
THIS AND GETTING THE BALL
ROLLING UP ROLLING ON THAT
DOING THAT THINKING WOULD HELP
AVOID UNNECESSARY DELAYS AND
THEREFORE UNNECESSARY SPENDING
ON WARM. CHECK OUT. REGARDING
THE PROPOSED A HEALTHCARE
FACILITY REPAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
CENTER IN NORCO- THE PROJECT HE
C. R. INDICATES THAT THE
PROJECT WOULD BE COMPLETED AND
TELLS. A FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND AT THAT POINT BASED
ON CDC OURS OWN PROJECTIONS OF
THE INMATE POPULATION IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THE STATE COULD
BE IN A POSITION TO. BE CLOSING
ITS THIRD PRISON FIVE FALL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT- C. OR C. MAY
BE IN A GOOD LOCATION AND HAVE.
SOME THINGS GOING FOR IT BUT-
IT AT THIS POINT THE DEPARTMENT
HASN'T PUT FORWARD A PLAN- TO
ACT TO DEAL WITH THE FULL SCOPE
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THAT C. OR C. SO. WE DON'T
REGARD THAT AS A LONG TERM OR
IN OTHER WORDS WE DON'T REGARD-
MINIMAL FIXES OR TEMPORARY.
PATCHES ESSENTIALLY ON THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AT SEARS
SEE WHICH IS WHAT IS PROPOSED
EFFECTIVELY AS A LONG TERM.
PLAN FOR THAT FACILITY. SO
THEREFORE SO WE'RE CONCERNED IN
OTHER WORDS THAT. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS PROJECT IS FUNDED BY
THE STATE COULD BE. YOU KNOW
CLOSING HERE SEE BY THE TIME-
THE WORK OR ALREADY BEFORE THE
REPAIRS ARE COMPLETED WHICH
WOULD OF COURSE NOT BE COST
EFFECTIVE. SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL UNLESS
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN PROVIDE
HELLO AND A LONG TERM PLAN FOR
HOW LITTLE ADDRESS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND- ANY
OTHER- CHALLENGES WITH
OPERATING A FACILITY IN THE
LONG TERM. AND DEMONSTRATE THAT
THE- IN OTHER WORDS. OR IN
EITHER IN THE LONG TERM OR LONG
ENOUGH TO MAKE. THE REPAIR IS
WORTHWHILE ESSENTIALLY- TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES RICK REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
IT COULD RE REDIRECT THE
RESOURCES TO OTHER HIGH
PRIORITY INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THAT PERSON THAT ARE NOT LIKELY
TO BE CLOSED. AND THEN ON
FINALLY ON THE BROADER ISSUE OF
THE STATE SIGNIFICANT PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS- AS NOTED
IN YOUR GENDER AGENDA- WE HAVE
RECOMMENDEDTHAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE. THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A LONG
TERM STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT PERSON PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS- THIS
INCLUDES PROVIDING A LIST OF
THE SIGNIFICANT HIGH PRIORITY
PROJECTS THE DEPARTMENT THINKS
IT WILL NEED. AT THIS POINT TO
COMPLETE OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS- ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THINGS OF COURSE MAY CHANGE IN
THE FUTURE- WE ALSO THINK THAT
THE REPORT SHOULD INCLUDE AN
EXPLANATION OF HOW THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDERED VARIOUS
CRITERIA. IN SELECTING THESE
PROJECTS- FOR EXAMPLE IT SHOULD
CONSIDER OPPORTUNITIES TO. YOU
KNOW NOT JUST REBUILD
FACILITIES AS THEY ARE NOW BUT
CONSIDER REDESIGNING THEM IN A
WAY THAT WOULD ACHIEVE THAT BUT
YOU KNOW OPERATIVE OPERATIONAL
SAVINGS WORK- IMPROVED.
SERVICES FOR INMATES OR PERHAPS
CONSOLIDATING A WE'RE
RELOCATING PRISONS- THE STATE
SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER THE
POSSIBILITY OF FUTURE PRISON
CLOSURES AT IN TERMS OF HOW.
THINKING CARE HOW MUCH. IT
WANTS OR WHAT KIND OF TIME
HORIZON IT WANTS TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS AND TO PRESENT
INFRASTRUCTURE- I JUST NOTE
THOUGH THAT THE FOR THE FACT
THAT THE PRISON IS. EXCUSE ME
THE STATE IS PLANNING TO CLOSE
TO PRISON THAN WE THINK BASED
ON PROJECTIONS COULD BE IN A
POSITION TO CLOSE THREE
ADDITIONAL PRISONS. DOESN'T
ISN'T BUT THE PRIMARY DRIVER
BEHIND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE STRATEGY
REPORT BUT REALLY THE OVERALL-
SIGNIFICANT NEED AN
INFRASTRUCTURE IS WHAT DRIVES
THE FUNDAMENTAL NEED FOR A
PLAN. IN OTHER WORDS IF THE
STATE WERE CLOSING ZERO PRISONS
ARE FIVE PRESENTS IT STILL
NEEDS TO- ASSESS HOW IT'S GOING
TO ADDRESS. THIS MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
THANK YOU AND HAVE TO TAKE.
THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK-
MISTER BOARD FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO GET US A PLAN AT THE
BEGINNING OF MARCH- HOPEFULLY
THIRTY TWO SAID SOME LIGHT AND
ANSWERS INTO SOME OF THE ALLEY
OF COMMENTS. OUT THERE MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT- I DID HAVE A
QUESTION AS I LOOKED AT THE
DATA AND THE POPULATION I'M
BEING THE LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN
THE LAST THREE. DECADES AND
LOOKING AT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND EMPTY
BEDS- AND AS WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT. THE POSSIBILITY OF
ADDITIONAL CLOSURES OR AS THE
L. A. O. SPEAKS ABOUT AN
ADDITIONAL THREE CLOSER TH ON
THE TWO THAT ARE PLANNED. OUT
WHAT'S A COMFORTABLE CUSHION
FOR EMPTY BEDS- FOR THE STATE
TO MAINTAIN. BEFORE ANOTHER
CLOSER CAN HAPPEN. MISTER MAYBE
CDC ARE. CONDUCTED A PRESS-
WELL I BEGINNING IN IN ANSWER-
OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE THINGS THE
DEPARTMENT IS DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS THE AFFECTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN- ON OUR
POPULATION AND OUR OPERATIONS
AND- WITH THAT BERMAN HAS GONE
TO ANY STANDARD OF PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AS IT RELATES TO OUR
OPERATIONS AND OUR HOUSING
DECISIONS WITHIN THE PRISON
SYSTEM. SO WE'RE CERTAINLY IN A
IN A POSITION WHERE WE NEED TO-
FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM GET GET
TO THE NEXT- GET GET AROUND THE
CORNER WELL WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO- LOOK FORWARD TO HAVE SO
MUCH OF THE STATE NEEDS TO-
WITH A VACCINATION STRATEGIES
ANOTHER STRATEGIES- SO THAT WE
CAN. GET BACK TO WHATOUR NEW
NORMAL OPERATION IS GOING TO BE
WITHIN THE PRISON SYSTEM I
THINK THAT THOSE THINGS NEED TO
OCCUR ALONG WITH THE CONTINUED
REVIEW OF POPULATION TRENDS
POPULATION PROJECTIONS IN ORDER
TO GET TO A POINT WHERE- MORE
THAN THE TWO PERSONS THAT WE
HAVE COMMITTED TO CLOSING- CAN
CAN BE LOOKED AT. THAT'S KIND
OF IT IN A NUTSHELL I BELIEVE
THE PARTNER FINANCE MIGHT HAVE.
SOMETHING THAT. LENITION I
DEPART OF IMPACTS. THANK YOU
ADAM I WOULD ADD THAT CURRENTLY
THERE IS ISOLATION SPACE THAT
SATISFIED DUE TO KOBE THE IRA
IN CASE ABOUT BREAKS AND THAT
HAS REDUCED CAPACITY BY SEVERAL
THOUSAND BEDS. AND THERE'S ALSO
ROUTE WE'RE STILL EXPLORING THE
FUTURE USE OF DORM BETH OUT
WHICH IF THAT IS DISCONTINUED
COULD ALSO REDUCE OUR CAPACITY
BY SEVERAL THOUSAND MORE BAD.
IF I CAN I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT LOOKING AT
FUTURE PRISON CLOSURES BEYOND
THAT TO THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED. THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DEFINITELY COMMITTED TO
RIGHT SIZING THE PRESENT SYSTEM
AND THAT'S HOW STOP ALL MANNER
AND I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT AYE
AYE AYES AND TALKED ABOUT WE'VE
REDUCED OUR CONTRACTED PRISON
CAPACITY BESIDES. IT THE
ARTISTIC PADS WERE TERMINATED
IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SIX OF THE SEVEN IN
THE STATE CONTRACTED BEDS HAVE
BEEN. TERMINATED ON OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE BUDGET
REFLECTS CLOSER OF THE FINAL
AND STATE CONTRACT THAT HAD
THE- VISIBILITY BY NAY OF
TWENTY ONE. FOR WE HAVE
COMMITTED AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLOSING TWO
PRESENTS- AS WE TALK ABOUT TV I
AM TWENTY ONE AND A SECOND
PERSON A TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND WHEN WE IDENTIFY DVI
FOR CLOSER IT WAS THE HEAD OF
THE OUR STATUTORY NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT AND WE'RE ON TRACK
TO IDENTIFY THE SECOND PRESENT
BY THAT JANUARY TWENTY. TO THE
DEADLINE AS WELL THAT SAID WE
BELIEVE IT'S STILL PREMATURE TO
IDENTIFY THE TIMELINE FOR
FUTURE PRISON CLOSURES BEYOND
THAT YOU. IT'S A MAJOR DECISION
THAT HAS ENORMOUS IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE STAFF WHO WORK THERE
THE INMATES HOUSED THERE AND
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
COMMUNITIES. AND SO IT'S A PATH
WE DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN UNTIL.
RELATIVELY CERTAIN IT CAN BE
COMPLETED. AND THERE'S NO OF
FACTORS THAT REALLY PLANTED
ABOUT ONE OF THOSE IS THE
IMPACTS OF KOBE- LIKE I SAID
THERE'S- CURRENTLY ISOLATION
SPACE- AS OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'LL
BRING THE VIRUS UNDER CONTROL
WITH OUR AGGRESSIVE TESTING
PROTOCOLS IN THE DISTRIBUTION
OF VACCINES BUT THE OVERALL
TRAJECTORY WITHIN THE PRISON
SYSTEM STILL REMAINS UNCERTAIN.
THE SAFETY OF INMATES AND STAFF
ARE OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE AND
WE WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
PREMATURELY CONSOLIDATING ANY
INSTITUTIONS. COURTS ARE
WATCHING AND LOOKING OUT HOW
THESE ISSUES WILL BE HANDLED
LONG TERM AND WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THESE COMPLICATED
LEGAL IMPLICATIONS AS WE
CONSIDER FUTURE POTENTIAL
PRISON CLOSURES. IN ADDITION
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT MAKING RELATIVELY
PERMANENT DECISIONS LIKE
CLOSING PRISONS BASED ON LONG
TERM PROJECTIONS IS RISKY. CDCR
GOOD AT OUR POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND ARE FAIRLY
ACCURATE WITHIN A YEAR TO YOU
USUALLY WITHIN A COUPLE OF
PERCENTAGE POINTS WHICH IS
USUALLY LESS THAN TWO THOUSAND
INMATES MARGIN OF ERROR.
HOWEVER THE FURTHER OUT YOU GO
THERE IS A HIGHER MARGIN OF
ERROR AND IT CAN BE 10215% OR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND INMATES. AND
THAT'S NOT AN INDICTMENT OF THE
PRODUCTIONS BUT RATHER
REFLECTION OF HOW THE POLICY
CHANGES HAVE HAPPENED OVER THE
YEARS AND ILLUSTRATES WHY
MAKING LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
DECISIONS. BASED ONLY ON MULTI
YEAR PROJECTIONS IS RISKY. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE BELIEVE IT
SO PREMATURE TO AND IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL PRISON CONVERTERS
BEYOND THIS YEAR. AT YOU FOR
THAT I- TO SEE CLEAR. WE I WAS
NOT ASKING TO IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
CLOSER EARTH ANYTHING THIS IS
IN LINE WITH A THEY'RE ASKING
FOR A TEN YEAR LONG TERM PLAN.
THAT WILL HAVE MANY VARIABLES
IS ONE OF THE MANY VARIABLES
THAT WE THINK WOULD BE INCLUDED
IN THAT DISCUSSION AND THOSE
DECISIONS- AND SUCH AS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE BEING
SMART WHILE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE THINK ABOUT THE
MERGER AND ERROR OF. THE SIZE
OF THE POPULATION. AND I WANT
TO BE REALISTIC THAT BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE WITH US FOR A
WHILE IT'S NOT GOING AWAY.
RIGHT AWAY I ALSO WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE ERROR OF NOT
PLANNING ACCORDINGLY AND THEN
HAVING TO RESPOND TO OUR VOTERS
OF TAX DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
WASTED. ALONG THE WAY AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH THIS CLOSER IN OUR
WE'VE INVESTED. RECENTLY CLOSE
TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
PERSON WAY ABOUT THE GROWTH.
OUT THERE SO- DOES I THINK AT
THIS POINT TO KEEPING THAT
GOING TO GIVE ME A DIRECT
ANSWER BUT- COME. EARLY
MARCHING IN TO GIVE US A REPORT
I HOPE THIS IS PART OF IT'S
GOING TO BE CONSIDERED IN YOUR
DEFENSE ANALYSIS OUT THERE. NOT
WITH THAT I'M GOING TO PASS IT
OVER TO MR LACKEY. WHO I KNOW
HAD SOME QUESTIONS. YEAH JUST
REAL. I I A PRE. THE
INFORMATION AND SOME OF THE
CRITERIA THAT WAS EXPRESSED. ON
NOW. WHAT IS CONSIDERED BEFORE
THEY DO THE- THE SHUTDOWNS. BUT
ONE OF THE CRITERIA THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND TRIGGERED A
QUESTION MY MIND YOU TALKED
ABOUT. LONG TERM INVESTMENT
COSTS. AND LAST YEAR I TALKED
ABOUT A PRISON THAT'S IN SUCH
DEPLORABLE CONDITION. AND THAT
WAS PLEASANT VALLEY. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S PART OF
THE CONSIDERATION. FOR THE SHUT
DOWNS BUT- I I'M ASSUMING THAT-
THE REPAIRS THAT. THAT PRISON
NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE VERY VERY
COSTLY. AND I JUST WONDERED IF
THAT WAS. ONE OF THE STRONG
CRITERIA BASED ON WHAT YOU
SHARED WITH ME. WITH US WITH
THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THAT QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WACKY. THERE ARE
TWO SIDES TO DETER THE FACILITY
POINTED BY THE RELEASE OF THE
CLOSURE- ONCE SOMEONE HAS TO DO
WITH INVESTMENTS HAVE ALREADY
OCCURRED- BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT'S THE QUESTION OF LOOKING
FORWARD AND SAYING WHAT A
DIFFERENT REPAIRS ARE GOING TO
BE NEEDED. AT THAT LOCATION. SO
I THINK THAT THE THINGS. FOR I
HAVE TO DO WITH THE FUTURE OF
NEW FOR REPAIR- DECISIONS WILL
PROJECT HAVE BEEN COMPLETED
ALREADY THOSE DECISIONS WERE
BASED FIVE TO SIX YEARS
PREVIOUSLY- AND REALLY WE NEED
TO LOOK AT GOING FORWARD I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT IT PLEASANT VALLEY- WE
HAVE. A COMPLETED. EVEN PROJECT
A PLEASANT VALLEY WHERE ALL THE
HOUSING UNITS. YOU MENTIONED
HAVE BEEN REALLY FOR LEAKING
CONDITION FOR NUMBER OF YEARS-
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FINISH ARE
REGROUPING EVERYTHING ON
HOUSING UIT- IN THE SUPPORT
SPACES AT PLEASANT VALLEY SO IT
ACTUALLY. IS IN A MUCH BETTER
CONDITION TODAY THEN IT WAS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I'VE I'VE BEEN A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE SINCE I GOT
ELECTED TWENTY TWELVE EFFECTIVE
CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE. AND
IT'S A DISCUSSION. THEN ABOUT A
REPAIRING- PRISONS THAT HAVE
COME TO THE END OF USEFUL LIFE
THAT NEEDED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND WITH A
DISCUSSION ABOUT. POSSIBLY
CLOSING OR BUILDING NEW ONES
GOING TO A BOND. AND THE
DEPARTMENT THEN WAS ASKED FOR
SOME TYPE OF GENERAL OVERVIEW.
OF THE FACILITIES TO CONDITIONS
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO
GO GET NEW FACILITIES. OR
WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO SHUT
SOME DOWN. THIS IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED. ANY ANALYSIS FROM CDC
ARE. EITHER IT'S BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO. EITHER'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE INCOMPETENT WHY JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S A THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT COLONEL PROBLEM
WITH THIS THIS IDEA OF
PROVIDING THE BEST FACILITIES
FOR NOT ONLY TO PRISON GUARD TO
THEIR BUT THE INMATES THAT ARE
THERE. I WOULD SUGGEST MADAM
CHAIR. THAT ANY COMPETENT REAL
ESTATE COMPANY COULD GO INTO
CDC OUR LOOK AT OUR FACILITIES
AND MAP OUT A PLAN. OF HOW
TRIED TO REHAB THE EXISTING
FACILITIES SO THEY MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE SYSTEM SHOULD
HAVE. BUT MOST IMPORTANT.
DISCOVER WHICH FACILITIES HAVE
COME TO THE END OF THEIR USEFUL
LIFE. AND MOST IMPORTANT THAT
WE DON'T INVEST IN FACILITIES.
THAT WE MAY ULTIMATELY TEAR
DOWN SELL OR ABANDON. I
REMEMBER A MILLION DOLLAR
KITCHEN THAT WOULD PEOPLE
WANTED TO BUILD IN A IN A
FACILITY THAT WAS RUN DOWN
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE SAID NO TO.
SALT I THINK AT THIS POINT WE
SHOULD STOP WAITING. STOP
ALLOWING CDC ARE TO DRAG THEIR
FEET ON THIS ISSUE. I WE OWE IT
TO THE TAXPAYERS WILL TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THOSE
BUILDINGS. TO PROVIDE THE TYPE
OF FACILITY THAT THEY NEED TO
DO THEIR WORK. AND IF WE HAVE
TO TAKE OR FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
FIND AT FUNDING SO WE CAN DO IT
OURSELVES WE SHOULD BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IN THE LONG RUN. WE
WILL SAVE TAXPAYERS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. WE MAY ACTUALLY SAVE
SOME LIVES IN BUILDINGS THAT
MAY HAVE EXPRESSED THIS OR SOME
OTHER HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
INSIDE THEM. THAT WILL HELP US
MOVE FORWARD- THIS IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'LL BE QUITE FRANK
WITH YOU. I AM TIRED OF WAITING
THIS IS TIME THAT WE START
MOVING ON THE STATE'S AND QUIT
LISTENING TO. VETERANS
CURRENTLY TRYING TO TELL US.
THAT THEY CAN'T DO IT OR THEY
CAN'T MOVE FAST ENOUGH TO GET
THIS DONE. THAT AT THIS POINT
YOU SHOULD BE TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE. TO IT I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER INFO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- THIS THE URGENCY
FOR THE INFORMATION AND SHARE
WITH US NEXT WEEK IT'S BEEN
LONG OVERDUE. MY MATH MYELITIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY
QUESTIONS ARE AROUND THE LOOKED
OF ALL FACILITY AND THE L. A.
OWES A RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
POSITION CUTS **** AND THIS IS
TO THE DEPARTMENT FIRST WHAT IS
THE SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THE
WOMAN'S ARM FACILITY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
ARE THE TWO WHAT DO THE TWO
POSITIONS AND NOT. FACILITY
ACTUALLY DO. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- THE- CORPORATION OF
THE BUILDING HAPPY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY IS
THAT JUST UNDER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND. ONE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET THE
AMOUNT OF SQUARE FEET AT THE
OLD LOCATION INSTITUTION IS
MORE THAN ONE POINT TWO MILLION
SQUARE FEET. SO THE OTHER
ASPECT OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY IS
THAT IT IS THAT YOU SENT TO
OPERATING FACILITIES IN
STOCKTON ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FACILITY IS
ADJACENT TO IT AND THE
NORTHERN- CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL CENTER IS ADJACENT
TO OUR SO THERE ARE. ABILITIES
TO HAVE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
BETWEEN THOSE FACILITIES AND
HELPING ANY- PREPARING NAMES
ARE NOT BEING A STANDALONE
FACILITY IT DOES NOT HAVE THE
SAME. ISSUE OF GROUNDS-
COVERAGE ON IN LIKE SAID IT'S
MUCH SMALLER IT'S ONE HUNDRED
FORTY ACRES COMPARED TO SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE ACRES SO
THE PEOPLE AT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY
PRIMARILY- KEEP THE MACHINERY.
HANDLING IN ITS- AND OTHER
ELECTRONICS OPERATING- AND THEN
MANAGE CONTRACT WORK COMING IN
THERE TO DO WEED CONTROL. AND
OTHER ISSUES LIKE THAT. AND THE-
MANY- POSITIONS NEEDED. FOR
DEFAULT THIS POINT IS THE
TWELFTH. TO RUN TO RUN- ONCE
CLOSER. THAT IS THAT THAT'S OUR
ANALYSIS UP AT THIS TIME- WE
HAVE PERFORMED WE PUT TOGETHER
WORK LOAD ANALYSIS ON I'M NOT
CERTAIN IF IT IS GOING TO THE
ONLY HOPE SO WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH THE ONLY- REGARDING
THAT ONE THING I WOULD. POINT
OUT IS THAT- DO ALL DOES HAVE
AN OPERATING WATER AND
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT. AND
THEY WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE
OPERATING ALTHOUGH AT A MUCH
REDUCED CAPACITY BUT LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE PLANS DO
REQUIRE I PERSONALLY DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION TO GET MINIMUM
OF TWO IT MIGHT EVEN BE THREE
OF THOSE PAUL P. WISE OUR WATER
AND WASTEWATER. PLANT WORKERS
OBVIOUSLY THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
PENALIZED NEVER ASK FOR IT INTO
W. OUT BECAUSE THERE'S A
CERTAIN FUNDING INDIVISIBLE.
UTILITIES OF THE CITY OF
STOCKTON. THANK YOU. UGH THANK
YOU FOR THAT DOES ANYONE ELSE
HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS ON THE
FIRST ISSUE. MISTER CHANG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR-
I JUST WANT TO GO THROUGH AND
JUST DOUBLE. CHECK SOME OF JUST
THE NUMBERS I GUESS IN THE DO
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE- THE AYE
OUR AGENDA BRIEF IN FRONT OF
YOU. YEAH GREG ALLMAN. IT SAYS
THAT ROUGHLY THE- OCCUPIED
CAPACITY FOR THE PRISONS IS
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND SIX SIX
THREE ON PAGE TWO WITH A TOTAL
OF NINETY FOUR THOUSAND ON PAGE.
TO WITH IT BUT WHEN YOU ADD UP
ALL THE ADDITIONAL. NUMBERS
THAT. CORRECT. TO GET STARBURST
I ASSUME IT IS PERHAPS WE'RE AT
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED I CONSTRUCTION POP AND
ARE IN CUSTODY POP IS NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AS
OF. TODAY I WOULD JUST
WONDERING IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THE L. L. HOUSE IN TERMS
OF TWENTY TWENTY ACTUALS OF-
BUT A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND.
OF L. L. WANTS TO COMMENT. OUR
SORRY MISTER KING WHAT WHICH-
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR CHART
REGIONAL PAVE PAGE FIVE OF OUR
AGENDA IN MAY POPULATION AS OF
AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH WITH YOUR
PROJECTIONS OKAY POLITICS
DECEMBER SO THESE ARE JUNE
THIRTEEN POINT IN TIME NUMBERS.
NINE AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION
MEMBER ORGANIZATION SO THAT AND
THEN WITH. THAT HAS SINCE COME
DOWN YOUR SON. SO THE JUNE
THIRTY NUMBER IS AN ACTUAL
POPULATION. NUMBER THAT WE TOOK
FROM CITY SHARES POPULATION
REPORTS AS IN JUNE THIRTY.
TWENTY TWENTY. AND TWO THAT THE
NUMBERS LABEL LABELED PROJECTED
ARE FROM TCRS MOST RECENT
POPULATION PROJECTION REPORTS
WHICH ARE ALSO JUNE THIRTY
NUMBERS- AS WERE RELEASED WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET GOT A
SECURE YOUR JUNE THIRTY NUMBERS
KIND OF MORE IN LINE WITH THE
NUMBER ON PAGE TWO. IT LOOKS.
WITH IT. AVAILABLE THE NUMBER.
SORRY I'M NOT FOLLOWING THE
QUESTION OF HOW I MIGHT HAVE TO
PROCESS THIS A LITTLE BIT OF ON
AGAIN OFF A LITTLE BIT LATER ON
JUST JUST YOU KNOW WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THEM THE MEETING WE
HAD WAS THE LAST WEEK REGARDING
JUST ON GETTING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LONG ****
CAPITAL PROJECTION I HEARD YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT THAT YOU
THINK BY JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE US
THAT INFORMATION IS THAT
CORRECT. THE MARKET WILL BE
ABLE. WITH THE- JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWO- REQUESTED FOR
THAT INFORMATION. SOURCE I'M
SORRY SAY AGAIN COULD YOU SAY
THAT AGAIN I'M SORRY. YES THE
LITTLE REPORT LANGUAGE I
REQUESTED INFORMATION BY
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND ITS OUR COMMITMENT TO
COMPLETED BY THAT DATE. VERY
GOOD GREAT IN AND THEN AS AS
YOU. GO THROUGH THAT- DO YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF YOUR SORT OF
METHODOLOGY THAT YOU'RE GONNA
START TO. ON A CHOOSE FURTHER
CONSOLIDATION IN CERTAIN- TO A
SPECIALIZED COATED SUBSIDES HOW
HOW YOU WERE GOING TO. GO
THROUGH YOUR DETERMINE PROCESS
HOW YOU CONSOLIDATE THAT
PRISONERS IN THE FACILITIES. I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT TO
SHARE AT THIS TIME I BELIEVE
THE ONE OF THE KEY THINGS WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO DO TO START
WITH IS TO MEET WITH A VERY
STAKEHOLDERS. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- THAT THE DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS OBVIOUSLY
OUR HEALTHCARE PARTNERS INDIA
P. BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS COMES
DOWN TO THE DIFFERENT
SUBPOPULATIONS IN THE DIFFERENT
MISSIONS OF THE DIFFERENT
PERSONS- WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF WE WERE TO PROPOSED
CONSOLIDATION OF ANY. THAT THEY
HAVE SIMILAR MISSIONS AND
SIMILAR POPULATIONS THAT ARE
SERVED BY THOSE LOCATIONS- SO
THERE'S A LOT OF ANALYSIS THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED FOR US TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE PER HALF
PROJECTIONS OF HOW THAT MIGHT
CHANGE IN THE FUTURE. AND THEN
OVERLAY THAT WITH- THE PRISONS
THAT ARE EAGER GOOD CANDIDATES
FOR REMAIN OPEN GOOD CANDIDATES
POTENTIALLY FOR CLOSURE AND HOW
TO COORDINATE THE- SO I'M THE
FIRST ONE I DON'T HAVE. THIS IS
A PROCESS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE EMBARKING UPON- AND I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF THE DETAILS OF IT
TO SHARE WITH YOU WOULD. YOU
WANT TO SHARE THE DETAILS OF
HOW YOU CHOSE DVR. BUT IT COMES
DOWN TO THE- TRANSACTION TWO
ZERO SIX SEVEN AND WE HAD A
LITTLE DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME I'M SORRY I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE THE- LOCAL MEMORIZED. YEAH
I'M I'M GOING TO THE LIBRARY-
SO THE SIX ITEMS IN THAT PEOPLE
CODE R. COSTA OPERATE.
WORKFORCE IMPACTS SO POPULATION
AND GENDER SPECIFIC HOUSING.
LONG TERM INVESTMENT IN STATE
OWNED AND OPERATED PERSONAL
FACILITIES INCLUDING PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS. PUBLIC SAFETY AND
REHABILITATION AND THE
DURABILITY OF THE STATE
SOLUTION PRISON OVERCROWDING.
SO A NUMBER OF THE ITEMS THAT-
MOVED- DVR YOU TOWARDS THE
CLOSURE DECISION- SOME OF THEM
ARE PHYSICAL PLANT ITEMS WHICH
IS ONE OF THE SIX CRITERIA. THE
LOCATION IS PRONE TO FLOODING
I'M PLAYING ACCORDING A ARE A
CATASTROPHIC FLOOD I BELIEVE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX- THAT. CUT
OFF THE INSTITUTION FOR A
COUPLE OF DAYS FROM THE OUTSIDE
ROADS- WE HAVE CHRONIC ISSUES.
WITH POTABLE WATER AND
WASTEWATER DISCHARGE. DENIED
DUE TO ITS LOCATION I'M IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN SACRAMENTO RIVER
DELTA AREA. I'LL BE ON THE
FACILITY ISSUES THERE WERE
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS. I GOT
SOME MISTER BORK JUST JUST OUT
OF CURIOSITY WHY WHY DID THIS
FACILITY STAND OUT OVER THE
OTHER. THIRTY SOME FACILITIES
IN THE SYSTEM. I DID DID YOU
DID YOU TAKE EACH THOSE. SIX
CAL AND PENAL CODE US THEM.
POINTS OR PERCENTAGES AND THEN
RANK THAT CAME OUT RANKED
NUMBER ONE. IT WAS NOT THE
NATURE OF THESE DIFFERENT
FACTORS IN THE NATURE OF OUR
THIRTY FOUR STATE OWNED AND
OPERATED INSTITUTIONS DIDN'T
ALLOW ITSELF TO ANY SORT OF MAP
EQUATION IN ORDER TO REACH THAT
CONCLUSION. SO THERE BUT THEN
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU MEAN
COMPLETELY ARBITRARY DECISION
THAT. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THING I WOULD NOT REFER
TO DECISION F. AS ARBITRARY.
YOU HAVEN'T PROVIDED ANY
EVIDENCE. TO THE CONTRARY.
THERE ARE ERIC SWANSON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
FISCAL SERVICES IN ADDITION TO
SOME OF THE FACILITY ISSUES
THAT WERE A DVR THAT WE
CONSIDERED WE ALSO WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE IMPACT TO WORK
FORCE WAS LESSENED BY CHOOSING
THAT FACILITY. AND IT HAS A MIX
OF POPULATION MINIMUM AND
MAXIMUM THAT MADE SENSE FOR
YOUR HANDS WELL WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
BACKING INTO ARE YOU CHOSE DVI
YOUR TICKETS NOT. THAT YOU'RE
NOT WALKING US THROUGH HOW YOU
CHOSE THE VIA. MEETING SOUNDS
LIKE YOU CHOSE DVI AND NOW YOUR
GIVE ME THE REASONS. WHY DVI
FITS. BUT YOU'RE NOT WALKING ME
THROUGH THE METHODOLOGY OF HOW
YOU ARRIVED AT THE DECISION.
THE DATA WAS COLLECTED FROM A
VARIETY OF SOURCES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- THAT WERE REACHED
THAT. APPROXIMATED THE SIX
CLOSER FACTORS THAT WERE LISTED
IN THE PENAL CODE SECTION OF
DATA THAT YOU CAN SHARE WITH US.
I WOULD HAVE IS KNOCKED OUT OF
IT I WOULD THAT WAS GIVEN BY
ALL I HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO SEEK
PERMISSION TO SEE HOW THAT DATA
CAN BE SURE. I WAS JUST ONE
PART OF PROVIDING DOWN ON
FACILITY SITE. WERE IS DOWN IT
WASN'T PROVIDED ON STAMPING ON.
I'M SORRY YOUR METHODOLOGY IS
NOT VERY CLEAR I'M HAVING VERY.
THOUGHT HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
FOLLOWING YOUR METHODOLOGY. AND
THE REASON IT'S IMPORTANT IS IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW BETWEEN THREE TO FOUR
TO FIVE MORE FACILITIES TO-
POTENTIAL CONSOLIDATE WHICH WE
THINK IS A GOOD STEP WE DO YOU
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE. ON A-
SET OF CRITERIA THAT YOU WOULD
YOU SAY IT'S IN THE CODE WHICH
WE APPRECIATE- BUT THAT THERE
IS A WAY THAT- ALL OF US HERE
COULD FOLLOW. FOLLOW THAT
CRITERIA AND THERE'S A CERTAIN
METHODOLOGY- AT THIS POINT WHAT
YOU'VE DESCRIBED IS COMPLETELY
ARBITRARY AND VERY CONFUSING.
SO I WOULD DESCRIBE IT AS
COMPLETELY ARBITRARY I HAVE NO
OTHER CHOICE BUT TO USE THAT
WORD BECAUSE YOU'VE GIVEN ME.
NO EVIDENCE TO THE CONTRARY.
TAKING I'M TAKING A LACK OF
RESPONSE BY- SILENT KNOWLEDGE
MENT OF. THE TRUTH. WELL WHAT I
TELL YOU THIS WE HAVE EXPLAINED
THAT IT WAS DONE IN A MANNER
THAT GATHER DATA WELL I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT ANSWER IS
NOT SATISFACTORY TO YOU BUT
THAT THAT DIDN'T THAT WAS THE
DEAL AND I DON'T KNOW WAS DONE
BY TICKET GATHERING DATA IN A
COMPARISON OF THAT DOWN UP
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT SEGMENTS
OF. THE DEPARTMENT IN ORDER TO
REACH A DECISION BY
DEPARTMENTAL LEADERSHIP IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE DOCTOR
MORE COMING WE COULD GATHER
SAME DIED AND WE COULD. YOU
KNOW AGAIN USE YOUR. SAME
METHODOLOGY TO PICK FOR
FACILITIES. ROCKETS THE SAME TO
YOU HOW DID YOU ARRIVE HOW DID
WE ARRIVE ON TO SAY WILL REDUCE
THE SIX CRITERIA WE JUST CHOSE
FOUR FACILITIES WE THINK.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BACK TO ME. AND I TELL
YOU WHAT WE THINK ABOUT. I HEAR
YOU. MISTER CHANG I'M SAYING IS
THAT THAT WOULD BE A LEGITIMATE
WAY FOR A LIST OF CLOSER TO
BEING TO BE A PUT TOGETHER OKAY
GRATEFUL WITH THEM WE CAN
COMPARE THIS WE'LL DO OUR LIST
YOU GUYS. DO YOUR LESS. WOULD
THAT BE A ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT.
WOULD YOU RATHER JUST HARRIS
SHARE WITH US YOUR METHODOLOGY
ON HOW TO DO AS WE GROW UP IN
THE SAME PAGE. SEE FURTHER OUR
GUIDANCE ON THAT ISSUE AND WE
WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH WITH THE
COMMITTEE REGARDING THAT
QUESTION YEAH WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO KNOW WHO YOU'RE-
SEEKING GUIDANCE FROM BECAUSE
WE COULD POTENTIALLY SEE GUYS
FROM THE SAME PEOPLE TO. IS
THAT THE SOURCE FROM THE
SECRETARY IS OUT FROM. YEAH I
REPORT TO THE SECRETARY SHOULD
BE FROM THE SECRETARY'S OFFICE
GREAT WE CAN WE WILL SEEK HER.
PERMISSION AS WELL- GET GIVEN
THE- WHEN ARE YOU AND I GET THE
REASON THE REASON WE REPHRASE
IT IS BECAUSE OF THE NEXT
FOLLOWING AGENDA ITEMS TO AND I
APOLOGIZE TO I THINK IT'S A
THREE I THINK WE WERE WE'VE
REITERATED AND COMMITTEE BEFORE
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
DESPITE THE FACT THAT AGAIN THE
LIST SEEMS LIKE A VERY GOOD
LISTED. THEY SEEM LIKE THEY
NEED TO BE REPAIRED AND I'M
SURE YOU CAN LET US KNOW- THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR EACH OF ALL
OF THOSE REPAIRS ON BUT THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT MET THE
METHODOLOGY SO WE DON'T APPROVE
AND- SIGN OFF ON REPAIRS THAT
DON'T NEED TO BE DONE
ESPECIALLY FOR FACILITY MAYBE
SLATED FOR CONSOLIDATION OR
WILL BE MAY BE REDUCING THE
POPULATION SIZE. SO THAT THAT'S
WHY THIS IS IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE SORT OF- YOU KNOW ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US
TO DO THE TEN YEAR PROJECT
WITHIN GOTTA BE EXTRAORDINARILY
HELPFUL BUT BUT THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME WITH
APPROVING MANY OF THESE THAT
CAPITAL COSTS AND WIFE THERE
WHY THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
LIST KEEPS KIND OF GROWING
BECAUSE WE'RE UNABLE TO. TO
GET- THE DATA IN SINCE THE IN A
REPORT WILL BE TO US IN- YOU
KNOW BEFORE BUDGET TIME I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY THE I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY OUR METHODOLOGY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE ARRIVING AT
APPROVING OR NOT APPROVING-
THIS LIST OF WHAT'S WHAT SEEMS.
LIKE A REASONABLE REQUEST. DO
IT I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE
INACTION ON OUR- OKAY. I DON'T
HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
BASED ON THE FIRST AGENDA ITEM
THANK YOU MESSENGER. THANK YOU-
YOU HEARD IT AT THE BEGINNING
EFFORT AND AT THE END OF THE
ISSUE- THAT. LITTLE MORE INPUT
INTO METHODOLOGY I'M PLANNING
TO THAT WE ARE. BEING MINDFUL
OF PROJECTIONS OF POPULATIONS
BUT ALSO OF OUR TAX DOLLARS
THAT IS MUCH APPRECIATED AND
LONG OVER DUE. I ANSWER LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY A MORE
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP. I
WITH THAT. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND ITEM.
IF WE'RE GETTING. MY NAME IS
CHRIS LEAD FROM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT CITY
ARE ALSO THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE SITE AND
AS OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA I'LL
TOUCH ON THE PROPOSALS- RELATED
TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDED
FROM STATE OPERATIONS FUNDING
THEN I'LL SUMMARIZE THE PUBLIC
PROPOSALS. AND HIGHLIGHT A FEW
OF THOSE. THE FIRST NOVEL IT
LOOKED ABOUT IS THE FIFTEEN
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS. THIS FUNDING
SUPPLEMENTS THE BASE SPECIAL
REPAIR FUNDING- THAT WE RECEIVE
HER TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WILL ALLOW CDCR TO PURSUE A
GROUP OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
DESIGNED AND READY TO PROCEED
TO CONSTRUCTION IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I DON'T
LIVE IN YOUR GENDER OR SEVERAL.
THAT WE INTEND TO PURSUE WITH
THIS FUNDING. I'D LIKE TO DRAW
FINALLY FIFTY ISSUES RENEW KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS AND
MAINTAIN. THEM THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING WILL ALLOW A FIFTY
THREE YARD TO ADDRESS URGENT
REPAIRS AS WELL AS TO HELP
AVOID CONVERGENCE THE REPAIRS
IN FUTURE YEARS I PERFORMING
PLANNED PREVENTATIVE REPAIRS
AND SYSTEM REPLACEMENT. AT THE
NEXT POSTAL I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS
IS A FOR THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION REPLACEMENT THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES- THAT INCLUDES ONE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND TO
DESIGN THE REPLACEMENT AND THE
BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THIRTY TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR CONSTRUCTION
AND THE FOLLOWING BUDGET YEAR.
ROOF REPLACEMENT IF NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE DETERIORATED
CONDITIONS OF THE EXISTING
GROUPS THAT SEVERELY IMPACT
HOUSING CONDITIONS AN INMATE
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSALS REFLECT THE
REQUIRED INFORMATION FOR FUTURE
READ REPROACH ACT SPECIFICALLY
INSTITUTIONS WITH HIGHER BIRTH
MEDICAL AND AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT MISSIONS WERE
GIVEN HIGHER PRIORITY AS
INMATES AT THESE LOCATIONS ARE
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO HARM FROM
CONDITIONS FOR ALL THINK
LEAKING ROOFS- IN HOUSING
PROGRAM LOCATIONS. I'M NEXT TO
CAPITAL OUTLAY- SIXTY ARE. THAT
PRIORITIZES CAL POLY CRIED.
THAT ADDRESS ORDER MANDATE.
URGENT KERR LIFE TAKING UPGRADE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND
PROJECTS TO WORK WITH. THE
PARTICIPATION. THANK INCLUDES
SIX OUT PROPOSED AND THREE THAT
ARE TO PROVIDING ADEQUATE
FACILITIES RELATED TO-
COMPLAINTS OF PLANNING BOARD
DIRECTIVES. TO BETTER RELATED
TO SUPPORTING SUCCESSFUL
DELIVERY OF PROGRAMMING TO
ENHANCE AND ONE TO PROVIDE A
SAFE HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT FOR
MEDICALLY SENSITIVE INMATES
PATIENTS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PREVENTION PLAN FOR HEAT
RELATED PATHOLOGIES REQUIRED BY
THE HOME COURT. A QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THESE
PROPOSALS- IT'S A NEW PROJECT.
SHE REQUESTED ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DESIGN OF THE
AIRPORT PROJECT. EVENTUALLY AT
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY. ROGER ECHO. LATER
ONCE A PAPER IN REASONABLE TREE
EDUCATION AND OFFICE WITHIN
FACILITY HAPPENED SHE AND FATF
THIS PART WILL OR AT SIX
PROGRAMS I PROVIDING IN TEMP
FOR INMATES TO RECEIVE
TREATMENT AND EDUCATION HIGH
TEMPERATURES IN THESE AREAS
LEAD TO MISTREATMENT. AND
EDUCATION HOURS. SIX REQUEST
THAT ARE FOR YOU IN CASE OF-
BECAUSE PRODUCTS. THE FIRST OF
THOSE IS THE AIR COOLING
PRODUCT IN FACILITY IN OF THE-
AND FOR. WE IS MEDICARE REST IN
THE HIGH RISK POWER. OUT THERE.
IN FIFTY WITH THEIR- PREVENTION
FOR HE REALLY HEALTH FOR BY THE
COMING GOVERNMENTS EARLIER. WE
THERE'S THE HUNDRED TWENTY
SOUTH DLLARS PER. FOR THE
WORKING DRAWING PHASE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
OFFICIALS COUNTY MEDICAL
PREPARATION ROOM UNIT THE FIVE
WHICH IS NEEDED TO SUPPORT
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION AND
ENHANCED OF PATIENT PROGRAM.
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION IN
THE PROJECT WILL INCREASE STAFF
PRODUCTIVITY AND SUPPORT TIMELY
AND MAKE PATIENT ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
PLOT OF COURSE AMERICANS. LAST
DON'T KNOW HOW IS THE SUB
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM PROJECT PHASE TWO I
KALPETTA THICK PRESENT. THIS
PROJECT IS ALSO NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS HEALTH CARE FACILITY
NEEDS IDENTIFIED IN- THE
RECEIVER TURNAROUND PLAN OF
ACTION- DURING CONSTRUCTION WE
DETERMINED THAT THEY THINK
FUNDING IS NOT ADEQUATE
COMPLETE THE PROJECT
SPECIFICALLY INCREASE COSTS
TRIBUTE TO DESIGN ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS RELATED TO THE
INTEGRATION OF THE FIRE ALARM
SYSTEM INTO THE SITE WIDE
MONITORING SYSTEM MODIFICATIONS
TO THE FIRE WATER SUPPLY AND
RELOCATE HELLO EVERYONE. IT IS
TO WORK WITH ALSO NOT VERY
RELATED TO PROVIDING FIRE
RECORDERS INCREASE ARE ALSO
RELATED TO THE EXTENDED JOB
DURATION FOR THE DESIGN ARIZONA
MANY MISSIONS JUST MENTIONED AS
WELL AS POPE IN NINETEEN THIS
RESULTED IN THE DIFFERENT COSTS
FOR INMATE WORD LABOR STUFF
HAVE TO LABOR AND GARDEN- BUT
I'M HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THIS A. O. HAVE A
CALM. KEEP AN EYE ON YOU KNOW
WHAT THE A. L. WE DO HAVE A- ON
THEM BUT FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION FOR
SPECIAL REPAIR AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AND THAT IS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE FUNDING GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE OR
SPECIAL PARA DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AT STATE
PRISONS THAT ARE NOT GOING AWAY
AND LIKELY WILL GET MORE
EXPENSIVE IF NOT ADDRESSED-
HOWEVER GIVEN THE- THAT THE
STATE IS. AS COMMITTED TO
CLOSING ONE PRISON- YET HASN'T
IDENTIFIED IT ONE ADDITIONAL
PRISON YET HASN'T IDENTIFIED
IT. AND BASED ON PROJECTIONS
COULD BE IN A POSITION TO CLOSE
ADDITIONAL PRISONS- WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THESE PROJECTS
IF. UNDERTAKEN AT ONE OF THOSE
PRISONS MIGHT. BE COMPLETED
AROUND THE TIME THAT THE PRISON
IS BEING CLOSE GIVEN THAT THESE
PROJECTS CAN TAKE A COUPLE
YEARS TO COMPLETE. SO WE
RECOMMEND. RESTRICTING THE
USAGE OF BOTH CDC AIRSPACE
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIAL PREPARED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUDGET AND A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION- SO THAT THEY
CANNOT BE SPENT AT PRISONS THAT
ARE LIKELY CANDIDATES ARE
STRONG CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE.
AND ADD TO- HELP AFFECTION WITH
THAT RECOMMENDATION WE THINK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
PROVIDE A LIST OF PRISONS THAT
IT BELIEVES ARE STRONG
CANDIDATES- EVEN IF IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY COMMITTING TO
CLOSING THEM- HOWEVER ABSENT
THAT BASED ON OUR INITIAL
REVIEW WE THINK THAT. DE
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
CENTER IN NORCO CALIFORNIA
MEN'S COLONY IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING FACILITY
AND- SOLEDAD AND SAN QUENTIN
STATE PRISON ALL APPEAR TO BE
STRONG CANDIDATES. FOR CLOSURE
GIVEN THEIR- EXTENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR NEEDS AND
HIGH OPERATIONAL COSTS RELATIVE
TO THEIR INMATE CAPACITY. THANK
YOU. HI THANK YOU WE ARE NOT
GONNA BE TAKING ACTION ON ANY
OF THESE ITEMS ON AND TO THINK
AGAIN AT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN
THAT WE REALLY NEED THAT PLAN
IN ORDER TO FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
WE AREN'T SPENDING DOLLARS
WISELY DURING THIS TIME OUT
THERE- I DO TWO FIVE ONE
QUESTION ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN.
THAT WAS OMITTED AND THAT TOO
BIRTH- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
VERSUS TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS THE
EVENTUALLY AT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS AND A COUPLE YEARS. IT
ROASTED THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS OVER LOOKING AT A 60%
INCREASE IN WHAT WAS ESTIMATED.
THIS IS JUST WONDERING WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN A COUPLE YEARS THAT
CREATED SUCH A DRASTIC INCREASE
TO. THE OVERALL MASTER PLAN FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. RIGHT
MADAM CHAIR EIGHTEEN MORTGAGE I
MEAN AGAIN FROM CDC ARE- WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO RESEARCH THAT
AND I GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WITH AN ANSWER- WE CAN SEE THAT
IN THE AGENDA BUT DID NOT HAVE
TIME TO FILL OUT THE PREVIOUS
MASTER PLANS. AND ANALYZETHOSE
NUMBERS SO WE WILL COMMIT TO A
GETTING AN ANSWER ON THAT- BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I WITHIN THE
NEXT A- WEEK TO WEEK AND A HALF.
AND SO I THINK THIS IN LINE
WITH OUR BUDGETEERS COMMENTS
OF. METHODOLOGY EIGHT I THINK
WE WANT TO SEE INFORMATION BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THE INFORMATION THAT WE AVE
COMING BEFORE US. ON IS WHEN WE
SEE THESE LARGE DISCREPANCIES
AND VARIANCE AND JUST A COUPLE
YEARS- OF YOU KNOW IN THIS CASE
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS I WOULD TO
MY DISTRICT WOULD GO REALLY
LONG WAY- IT MAKES US QUESTION-
AND HAVE A LOT OF THIS COME
FOR. YES IT DOES WHAT IT THANK
YOU THESE AT THIS POINT. ON AND
SIZE WERE MOVING FORWARD AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE PLANS-
THAT. MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY IS IMPORTANT THIS
IS WOULD BE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THAT. MISTER LUCKY YEAH I JUST
pAND BACK UP- ARCHER SILVA
RETAINS- REQUEST FOR
METHODOLOGY AND CRITERIA AND
THE REASON WHY THAT SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS WE HAVE
EIGHTY FACILITIES HERE. A
SLATED FOR IMPROVEMENTS THAT.
RACK UP A BILL OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE JUST SPENT FORTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN A
PRISON THAT WE'RE GOING TO SHUT
DOWN. I DON'T WE'RE LIKELY TO
REPEAT A SIMILAR- MISTAKE IF WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
THAT YOU'RE UTILIZING TO MAKE
THIS. TO READ IN THE CRITERIA
WE SHOULD PROBABLY HOLD OFF ON
THOSE REPAIRS AND SO I THINK
THE COMMUNICATION IS TO BE
STRONGER FOR THOSE OF US WHO
ARE SHARING IN THIS
RESPONSIBILITY OF MAKING THESE
DETERMINATIONS THAT SO WE'RE
NOT NECESSARILY TRYING TO BACK
YOU IN A CORNER WE JUST WANT
YOUR PARTICIPATION WE NEED
BETTER COMMUNICATION SO WE CAN
ALL BENEFIT FROM THIS. KIND OF
COMMUNICATION. MISTER THINK.
WOULD SUGGEST A PIGGY BACK ON
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
SO. YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION AT THIS TIME GOOD
I WOULD I WOULD WANT TO KNOW
THAT ANY OF THE EIGHTEEN
FACILITIES. YOU ARE BRINGING
FORWARD COULD NOT BE. ANY OF
THE HENCE THE UP TO FIVE
FACILITIES THAT YOU WOULD LOOK
AT CLOSING. SEOUL LIKE I SAID I
DON'T THINK YOU ARE PROBABLY
UNLESS YOU'RE PREPARED TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AS OF AT
THIS TIME. THE QUESTION WOULD
BE THAT ANY OF THE FACILITIES
YOU ARE BRINGING FORWARD- WOULD
THEY POTENTIALLY BE POSSIBLY
CLOSED IN THE NEXT. I GUESS
WHAT'S THIS AT THE TIME FROM
THE NEXT FOUR FIVE YEARS FOR
FIVE YEARS OR SO. FIVE FIVE
YEARS. WHAT WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION RIGHT NOW SO WE HEAR
THAT AND- WE WILL WE UNDERSTAND
THE COMMITTEES AND FIRST IN THE
SEPARATION AND THE FACT THAT
THERE'S TREMENDOUS FRUSTRATION
THAT THIS INFORMATION HAS NOT
BEEN PROVIDED UP TO THIS POINT
IN TIME. WITH THE GUYS THAT WE
WOULD JUST WANT ASSURANCES THAT
ANYTHING ON THIS LIST WOULD NOT
BE POTENTIALLY SLATED FOR
CLOSURE IN THAT NEXT FIVE
YOU'RE PIRED OF COURSE WE
CAN'T WE HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL WE
CAN SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
NEXT FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS OR SO
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
REASONABLE BUT AT LEAST I THINK
WE COULD AT LEAST SAY. WITHIN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS WE HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT WHAT COULD BE
SLATED FOR CLOSURE WE JUST
WOULD NOT WANT TO BE- SPENDING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY
OBVIOUSLY DOES LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES IF YOU HAVE TO KEEP THE
FACILITY OPEN FOR FIVE YEARS
YOU DO HAVE TO ME UP TO DO
CERTAIN CERTAIN TYPES OF
IMPROVEMENTS BUT- LET'S SAY FOR
EXAMPLE I WOULD IMAGINE YOU
DON'T NEED TO PUT A NEW ROOF ON
THE FACILITY GONNA. CLOSE IN
FIVE YEARS JUST JUST FOR
EXAMPLE. OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. MISTER JOHNSON-
AND I JUST WANT ALSO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR IF YOU HAD THIS
INFORMATION NOW TODAY TO OFFER
DISCRIMINATED I BELIEVE AND I'M
LOOKING AT ALL MY COLLEAGUES
HERE THAT YOU PROBABLY IF WE
HAD TO VOTE ON IT YOU PROBABLY
WOULD GET. APPROVAL OF
FACILITIES THAT DID NOT FIT
INTO THOSE CRITERIA OF
FACILITIES BEING CLOSED I THINK
THIS COMMITTEE IS DEDICATED AN
AND WILL GO HEAD TO MAKE SURE
WE PROVIDE THE RENOVATIONS THAT
ARE NEEDED SO THAT THESE THESE
FACILITIES ARE COMPLIANT AND
SAFE FOR EVERYONE AND CITED I
DON'T WANT YOU TO LEAVE WITH
YOU THINKING THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THIS AT ALL. OUT I THINK
THIS COMMITTEE ABSOLUTELY MUST
PROVIDE ALL THE FUNDING WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES ARE UP TO SPEED SUCH.
THIS IS FOR YOUR DAD THIS IS
FOR YOU AND WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THANKS. THANK
YOU ARE INTO COLLABORATION WILL
HOPEFULLY GET US TO. A BETTER
PLACE- WE ARE IN BUDGET THE
FIVE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT THE REALITY IS
THOUGH ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
OF US WERE ELECTED TO THIS. TO
THE TWO BODIES HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE- THE WHOLE BY TENANTS
THE TALIBAN. A LOT OF NEEDS OUT
THERE AND OUR COMMUNITY SAID
WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE
EVERYTHING OUT- AND SO. I LOOK
FORWARD TO IT ASSEMBLY-
INFORMATION A METHODOLOGY ALONG
THE WAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
INFORMATION I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WHERE WE HAVE VARIOUS-
NON CAPORALI PROPOSALS. THE
PANEL'S VERSION THREE WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
EACH OF THOSE THE PROPOSAL FOR.
A AND M. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AT THE BEGINNING- AND WE WILL
ASK QUESTIONS AT THE END. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT I
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M TAMMY
IRWIN FROM CDC OUR- CITY THEY
ARE CONSIDERED CONTRABAND
CELLPHONES DANGER AS- THEY ACT
AS A NEXUS FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AN INMATE
MISCONDUCT. INVESTIGATIONS
REVEALED NARCOTICS DISTRIBUTION
MURDER ATTEMPTED MURDER AND
CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT MURDER AND
HE'S OFFICERS. OTHER INMATES
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
CONTRABAND CELLPHONES HAVE BEEN
USED TO FURTHER HARASS VICTIMS.
THREATEN WITNESSES AND
OFFICIALS AND COMMIT FRAUD AND
IDENTITY THEFT. THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY USES A MULTI LAYERED
APPROACH TO DETECTING
CONFISCATE CONTRABAND
CELLPHONES. CDCR STAFF
ROUTINELY CONDUCTS CELL
SEARCHES AND EMPLOY THE USE OF
WALK THROUGH AND HAND HELD
METAL DETECTORS IN ALL INMATE
LIVING AREAS. CITIES THEY ARE
ALSO USES K. NINETEEN SEARCHES
BAFFERT'S ONE PROPERTY WHEN
ENTERING THE SECURED PERIMETER
AND PERFORMANCE ENHANCED
INSPECTIONS REGULARLY AT EACH
INSTITUTION ALL VISITORS AND
CONTRACTORS AND VOLUNTEERS ARE
PROCESSED THROUGH METAL
DETECTORS AND THEIR PERSONAL
BELONGINGS ARE THOROUGHLY
SEARCHED. HOWEVER SECULAR
DEVICES STILL. MAKE THEIR WAY
INSIDE THE SECURE PERIMETER. I
PART OF THE INMATE WERE TELL.
SYSTEM CONTRACT. AND A MULTI
LAYERED APPROACH CBC ARE
IMPLEMENTED MANAGED ACCESS
SYSTEMS EIGHTEEN OF ITS ADULT
INSTITUTIONS BEGINNING IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS WORKED TO FURTHER OPTIMIZE
THE CELLULAR BLOCKING
TECHNOLOGY BY WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP
STANDARD COURT ORDER LANGUAGE
AND PROCESS THESE. TO EXECUTE
WARRANTS TO DISABLE SERVICE TO
IDENTIFIED CONTRABAND DEVICES
AND ADD THOSE DEVICES TO THE
STORM FROM DATABASE TO
ELIMINATE THE POSSIBILITY OF
REACTIVATION CDCR HAS
PERMANENTLY DEACTIVATED NEARLY
TWO THOUSAND UNIQUE DEVICES
JUST SINCE AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY UTILIZING THIS. NEW
PROCESS. THE CURRENT INMATE
TELEPHONE CONTRACT EXPIRES
DISMAY AND THE RECENTLY
NEGOTIATED UP INTO
COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACT THE
COUPLE'S CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION TECHNOLOGIES FROM
AT. AS SUCH THE VCR IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH A
NEW CONTRACT TO CONTINUE
OPERATION OF THE MANIC CHECKED
THE SYSTEM AT THE EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS. I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO CAPTAIN A START UP
TO SPEAK ON THE NEXT TOPIC
WITHIN THIS ISSUE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHANNON
SPARKING A CAPTAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS. I'M I'M WORKING
ON IS THE ONE THIRTY TWO
IMPLEMENTATION SO PRIOR TO SB
ONE THIRTY TWO A WORKER WAS A
STOP LAST. WITH THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT- TO INCLUDE MEDICAL
MENTAL HEALTH PAROLE ADVOCATES
FROM THE COMMUNITY. YOU SEE ALL
THE HILLS AND THE PROGRAM
OFFICE- WITHOUT WORKGROUP
ESTABLISHED OR LIKE THE
FOUNDATION FOR SB ONE THIRTY TO
IMPLEMENTATION THE WORKER
DEVELOP POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO REQUEST TO
BE CLOTHING- SIGNATURE CLOTHING
AND PERSONAL ITEMS- FOR INMATES
REALTY- HOW CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY. I WANT
THIS TO BE ONE THIRTY TWO WAS
FINE THE DEPARTMENT REALLY HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING WE DROPPED
THE POLICIES AND REGULATIONS
CONSISTENT WITH SB ONE THIRTY
TO DEVELOP TRAINING AND
TRAINING ALL STAFF ALL CUSTODY
STAFF ON THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO. DEVELOPMENT
ADDITIONALLY WE DEVOLVED.
RECORD ALL IN MAYES GENDER
IDENTITY FOR THE EXISTING
NOTHING POPULATION- TO-
REQUESTS ARE DOLLAR FOR NATION
UNDER HONORIFICS THE PRONOUNS.
AND THEN ALSO- GENDER IDENTITY
FIELD WAS DEVELOPED IN OUR
STREETS. STRATEGIC THE VENDOR
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- I'M TO
RECORDED AND MIXED GENDER
IDENTITY SEVEN AND MADE
IDENTIFIES AS TRANSGENDER
INTERSEX OR NON BINARY- THERE'S
DIVISIONAL QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ASKED ABOUT THEIR HOW THEY
WOULD BE ALMOST SAFELY HOUSED
IN A MALE INSTITUTION OR A
FEMALE INSTITUTION. AND ALSO
WHO THEY FEEL MOST SAFE
SEARCHED BY MALE STAFF MEMBERS
ARE FEMALE STAFF MEMBERS.
ADDITIONALLY. AGENCY HAS
DEVELOPED A MEAN EDUCATION
MATERNAL STRICTLY TO BRIEF
COMMERCIAL THAT RUNS ON OUR-
INMATE EDUCATION CHANNEL OF A
BROCHURE. ON THE VIRTUAL TOWN
HALL. THE POSITIONS REQUESTED
AS MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE MEANINGFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB ONE THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU KNOW AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO AMY CASSIDY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS AMY COULD
SAY YES I AM THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE ACCOUNT OF
COUNTING WITH YOU SEE ARE. I'M
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL CANTEEN
RESOURCES FROM THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND. WE MADE THIS
REQUEST IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
MEET GROWING DEMAND FOR CANTEEN
ITEMS. ENSURE CANTEEN ACCESS TO
SEE THIS YEAR'S INCARCERATED
POPULATION. M. A. WELFARE FUND
WAS CREATED IN SECTION FIVE
ZERO ZERO SIX OF THE PENAL CODE
AND IT'S CONSIDERED A TRUST
HELD BY THE SECRETARY OF CDCR.
IN MAY WELFARE FUND USES
REVENUES IT GENERATES MET
MOSTLY FROM CANTEEN SALES TO
FUND ITS OPERATIONS. ALL
CANTEENS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
SELF SUPPORTING AND ALL
PROCEEDS OF THE FINDER REQUIRED
TO BE USED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
CANTEENS OF INCREASINGLY BECOME
A RESOURCE FOR THE DELIVERY OF
PROGRAMS WHICH BENEFIT OUR
POPULATION. BESIDES PROVIDING
FOOD AND SUNDRIES FOR PURCHASE
THE CANTEENS ARE NOW THE
DISTRIBUTION POINT OF OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICATION. AND READING
CLASSES WHICH OCCURRED DURING
NORMAL SHOPPING TIMES. WE ALSO
OFFER A HEALTHIER CANTEEN ITEMS
FOR SALE OF THOSE ITEMS ARE
DETERMINED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OUR FOOD STATEWIDE GOOD
ADMINISTRATOR. AND OUR
DIETITIANS. THE MAJORITY OF
THEM IT WILL OFFER FUND
EXPENDITURES ARE ITEMS
PURCHASED FOR RESALE. WITHOUT
THIS AUTHORITY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE ENOUGH ITEMS
TO SELL AT THE CANTEEN. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PURCHASE ITEMS THAT
WILL BE NEEDED FOR RESALE. DUE
TO OUR PROPOSED 10% RENDON
LIMIT INCREASE. WE'RE ALSO
REQUESTING SEVEN POSITIONS AT
SPECIFIC INSTITUTIONS TO HELP
US ENSURE ARE EFFECTIVE SERVICE
TO CDC OURS POPULATION FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AT THE CANTEEN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS REQUEST AND I'M NOW GOING
TO PASS THAT ALONG TO MY
COLLEAGUE KEITH ROBINSON. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEITH ROBINSON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD MINISTRY FOR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CHIEF THE
DIETARY. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL EALTH CARE
SERVICES DEVELOPER STATEWIDE
STANDARDIZED MENU WHICH WOULD
NOT ONLYMEET THE DIETARY
REFERENCE INTAKE AND THE
RECOMMENDED DIETARY ALLOWANCE
IT ALSO PROVIDES A HEALTHY
EATING PATTERN AS RECOMMENDED
BY THE DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICANS. AND YOU IDENTIFIES
CARBOHYDRATE CHOICES. ALLOWING
OUR INMATES LIVING WITH
DIABETES AND OBESITY TO MAKE
EDUCATED FOOD MENU CHOICES THIS
REQUEST IS TO INCREASE THE
STATE WIDE FEEDING RATE BY
TWENTY TWO CENTS PER INMATE PER
DAY FOR FOOD AND SUPPLIES TO
UPDATE THE FOOD MENU FOR ALL
INMATES TO PROVIDE HEALTHY FOOD
OPTIONS CONSISTENT WITH THE
200-015-2000 TWENTY DIETARY
GUIDELINES FOR AMERICANS.
FUNDING FOR THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BE MADE THROUGH THE STANDARD ON
ALLOCATED POPULATION ADJUSTMENT
WHICH IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. PROVIDING A
MENU LOWER IN SODIUM FAT
PROCESSED SUGARS OVER TIME CDCR
COMMITTEE GATE DIET RELATED
ISSUE. THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL NOTE IT IS COMMON FOR
PEOPLE TO GAIN WEIGHT UPON
INCARCERATION ANNA OBESITY IS
MORE PREVALENT AMONG PEOPLE
LIVING IN PRISONS. BUT IN THE
COMMUNITY CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AMERICANS HOT AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL GROUPS RECOGNIZE
THE WELL ESTABLISHED
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN OBESITY AND
CHRONIC DISEASE INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
DIABETES. KIDNEY DISEASE AND
THERE ARE DISCOUNTS. TRICIA AND
FOOD CHOICES CAN LEAD TO
CHRONIC DISEASE DEVELOPMENT
INDEPENDENT OF OBESITY. IN
ORDER TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING CANCER. IN CANCER
SOCIETY RECOMMENDS EATING MORE
FRUITS VEGETABLES AND WHOLE
GRAINS AND LIMITING THE
CONSUMPTION OF RED MEAT AND
PROCESSED FOODS IN RECENT YEARS
CTC ARTS VENUE FOCUS PRIMARILY
ON DAILY ALLOWANCES FOR
CALORIES HOWEVER IT FAILED TO
ADDRESS AN OVERALL HEALTHY
EATING PATTERN AS RECOMMENDED
BY THE DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICANS. GIVEN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DIET AND
HEALTH. CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS RAISED
CONCERNS THAT INMATES COULD NOT
MAKE EDUCATED FOOD CHOICES
BECAUSE CDC OURS MENU. OFFER
SUFFICIENT SUFFICIENTLY HEALTHY
FOOD ITEMS. THIS CDCR SPECS
THIS MENU CHANGE ALONG WITH
AVAILABLE. AVAILABILITY OF
HEALTHCARE CANTEEN OPTIONS TO
RESULT IN POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR ITS INMATES
POPULATION ALTHOUGH RESULTS MAY
NOT. SEEN UNTIL LONG TERM
OBESITY HYPERTENSION AND OTHER
DIET RELATED ILLNESSES AND
AFFECTS TO DECREASE WITHIN THE
INMATE POPULATION OVER TIME I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AFTER
THIS PRESENTATION. THANK YOU TO
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF MENTALLY
SORRY ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT I
MEAN ALEJO FOR COMMENT.
MOREOVER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS TO MAKE ON THE SURFERS
ON THE CELLULAR INTERDICTION
PROGRAM WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
HOWEVER IN REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL WE LEARNED THAT THERE
ARE RENEGOTIATED CONTRACT WITH
A VENDOR THAT PROVIDES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES FOR
INMATES AND WARDS OF. THAT
COULD NOT JUST ISN'T THIS IS
YOUR PRISONS. AND WANTED INFO
BECOMES THAT THEY ON THAT
CONTRACT WILL REACH OUT TO THE
DOOR STAFF TO LET THEM KNOW IF
WE HAVE ANY CONCERNS ON THE
CONTRACT- IN ON TO. THE TRAY OR
A HOUSE SEEING AND SO OF
PREFERENCES AS WELL AS THE
INCREASE CANTEEN RESOURCE WE
HAVE NO. WITH PEOPLE. ON THAT
HEALTHY MENU OPTIONS PROPOSED.
WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNED WITH A
PROVISION OF HEALTHY MEALS TO
INMATES HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT FOR CHANGE
TO THE MEALS PROVIDED TO
INMATES. STUDENTS ARE HAVE BEEN
USING THE MENUS THAT IT'S
PROBABLY TO CONTINUE USING SUCH
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. INSTEAD
THIS PROPOSAL IS ABOUT THE
FUNDING. STRUCTURE FOR THE
PROGRAM. RIGHT FROM ABOUT IN ON
THE IN MAKING BECAUSE HUNDREDS
FUNDING FROM HOLD YEAR.
ENTITIES HAS BEEN LEADER
FUNDING PAY FOR THESE MEALS
FROM. PLANT OPERATIONS POSITION
SUCH AS- AND LYFT. AND WHILE
THESE PROVISIONS ARE NECESSARY
FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE THEY'VE
BEEN HARPER FIELD ANGRY AS A
RESULT CDCR THOUGHT ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN SAVINGS FROM THESE
VACANT POSITIONS. BANCOR THOSE
FUNDING TO BEEN REDIRECTED PAY
THAT NEIL COSTS. STREETS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE USING THE
BACON SAVINGS JUST FOR ACROSS
OF THE MEETING IS GOING FORWARD
AS WE- BUT IF YOU CAME TO THAT
IT DOES NOT THINK THAT THEY-
SAY WILL BE SEPT. TO COVER THE
ENTIRE. FOR THE IN THE EMAIL
COSTS. BECAUSE THEY MIGHT HAVE
LOWER VACANCY FOR THEM CLOSER
USING THE NUMBER UNTIL POSITION.
AT THE END OF THE PANDEMIC
TEMPORARY WE'VE GOT SOME CALL
THE TIME BREAKING IT UP TO
POLICY REDUCE WILL SERVE PAYING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COMING TO AN
END AS WELL. THE LAST IMPACTORS
THINGS COULD POTENTIALLY
INCREASE THE ABILITY TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE TO THOSE. POSITIONS OUR
WE FIND THAT. INFORMATION IS
NEEDED ON THE VACANCY SAVINGS
CITIES OUR- THE BUDGET YOUR-
SPECIFIC HOW MUCH TO STATE THE
DEPARTMENT SPECTER BEEN THE
BUDGET YOU FROM THE TO THE-
HOWEVER I DID NOT ASK. AND HOW
TOTAL ESTIMATE SAY WOULD USE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT DO THEY
STRUCK ME HI LADIES WE RAFTING
THESE TO SUPPORT THEM IN COSTS
REASONABLE THE NEW YORK. GIVEN
THAT THIS IS A TOPIC IT FILLED
IN SO IT'S LIKE IN THE WILL BE
SAVINGS IN THIS AREA. HOWEVER
IT'S ONLY BE DONE ON TEMPORARY.
BASIS TO DRIVE. THIS SHORTFALL
PARTIALLY IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO HELP WITH
THAT KERN GENERAL FUND
CONDITION OTHER THAN TARGETED
TO ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES
POWER SHOULD NOT BE A LONG TERM
STRATEGY BECAUSE I WOULD BE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT FOR THE
FUNDING FOR THESE. OPERATIONS
POSITIONS WHAT IS PARTICULARLY
NOTABLE GIVEN THAT THESE
POSITIONS ARE INTENDED TO HELP
MAINTAIN THE PRISONS AND AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THIS
HEARING THEIR COMPLAINTS ARE
COUNTY. A STATE OF GREAT
DISREPAIR- FIND FIND THAT FOR
THE ACTION IS NEEDED TO FILL
THESE VACANCIES ON A LONG TERM
BASIS AND TO ADDRESS THE PANEL
CORRECTIONS WORKLOADS. AND WE
KNOWLEDGE THAT CITIES ARE HAS
TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS IN THIS
AREA AS OF JUNE TWENTY
NINETEEN- INCREASE RECRUITMENT
FOR THE POSITION BUT IT IS A
LOT OF COULD BE NECESSARY
BEYOND. RECRUITMENT INCLUDING
INCREASING THE PAY RATE
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER THEY
GIVES YOU READY ACCESS TO
SOMETHING THEY COULD CONSIDER.
AS WELL AS CONSIDERING HIRING
CONTRACTORS USING EXISTING
VACANCY SAVINGS INTO OTHER
POSITIONS CAN BE FILLED WITH
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES. MAKING
GREAT STEP IN MEETING FROM TOP
RATED POSITIONS EVERYBODY I
MEET WITH THE TRAINING SO. THEY
CAN'T PERFORM THESE FUNCTIONS.
GIVEN THESE FINDINGS RECOGNIZE
REQUIRE YOU CAN SEE ARE TO. ON
THE STATE STATE. IN
SPECIFICALLY ESTIMATED THE
TOTAL NOW OF TIME OUT CRAZY BIG
SAID THAT IS TO ONE POINT TWO.
OUR PRIVATE ESTá AND HOW PLANS
TO IT ESTIMATE STATE BEGINS.
AND THEN THEM. IS PROVIDED WE
RECKON WITH ACTUALLY GOVERNOR
PROPOSED UNTIL THEY SEE.
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS A COULD
DEMONSTRATE. THAT THERE IS NO
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FINALLY YOU. REQUIRING CDC
PROVIDED DETAILED PLAN TO
ADDRESS ALL. WERE AND DEVELOP
THIS AND THE MINISTRATIONS
CONSIDER THE ADVANTAGES AND
DISADVANTAGES OTHER QUESTIONS.
BEYOND THE RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
THANK YOU. QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU THINK MY FIRST
QUESTION MIGHT BE FOR MISS
IRWIN I SHOULD BE FROM MY ONLY
QUESTION AT THIS TIME I'M IN
LIMITATION MURDER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY HAVE A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO THE ALLEY AS
RECOMMENDATION. SURE THANK YOU
ARE WE ARE CONVINCED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY AS
THE L. A. R. SAID WE ANTICIPATE
THEIR SALARY SAVINGS TO BE
TEMPORARY AND THEY WON'T FULLY
BE AVAILABLE ON GOING TO THE
LEVEL THAT THEY CURRENTLY ARE
CDCR IS CURRENTLY INCREASING
ITS HIRING EFFORTS AGAIN AS
ALLI ASIDE EIGHT SOME OF THAT
THE VACANCIES ARE DUE TO COME
BAD- AND ALSO THAT TO PLAN
PRISON CLOSURES WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF AVAILABLE VACANCIES-
THE PROPOSAL ITSELF DOES ASSUME
THAT SOME SALARY SAVINGS WILL
BE AVAILABLE ON GOING WHICH IS
WHY THE REQUEST IS NOT FOR
THAT. FULL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE BUDGETED AMOUNT. AND THE
COST OF THE NEW MENU. WE'D ALL
LIKE SAY AB. WHAT WE THINK
PROVIDING HEALTHIER MEALS FOR
THE INMATES IS VERY IMPORTANT
THE DEPARTMENT THOUGHT THAT
THEY COULD NOT WAIT ANY LONGER
TO PROVIDE THOSE ME ALSO THEY
DID FIND SAVINGS TO MAKE SURE
THEY COULD IMPLEMENT IT HOWEVER
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE. THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU I THINK MY FIRST QUESTION
IS FROM IS IRWIN ON THE
CONTRABAND THEN LOOKING AT THE
LAST PAGE OF OUR BUDGET
DOCUMENT PAGE FOURTEEN AND WE
HAVE A TABLE THERE IF YOU HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE. YES I BELIEVE
SO AND SO IF I LOOK AT THIS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND KNOW THAT WE
STOP THEM VISITATIONS FROM MOST
OF THE YEAR WITHOUT THINKING
CAP INMATES FROM THE COUNTY
JAILS AS WELL BUT WE'RE STILL
SEEING FROM HIGH LEVELS OF
CONTRABAND. AND WE'RE SEEING
SOME INCREASES WITH SOME OF THE
CONTRABAND HERE. ON THIS TABLE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHT AS TO
WHY THIS IS HAPPENING. I AM A-
I AM WITH THE TECHNOLOGY A
DIVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
SO I'D LIKE TO DEFERRED TO ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
TO RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION. I
AM DIRECTOR IT CAN REALLY
CYCLE. DIFFERENT TACK TO ME
BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE ANY OF YOU
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT- IN MARCH WHEN
KOBE HIT MARKET THE MARCH WE
SEIZE VISITING WE CITIES HAVING
VOLUNTEERS VISITORS COMING INTO
OUR INSTITUTIONS. AND WE STILL
HAD- AN INFLUX OF CONTRABAND-
COMING INTO OUR INSTITUTIONS-
YOU WILL DIRECTLY. THAT YOU
KNOW THERE IS A PROBLEM WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE STILL DO
HAVE- CONTRACTORS COMING IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE ALL DO WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT- IT'S- IT'S
COMING AND YOU STAFF WELL. AND
WE ARE WORKING YES SERIOUSLY
AND WE DO HAVE A HOST OF
DIFFERENT- CONTRABAND- TOOLS
THAT WE USE TO- TRY TO FIND ALL
THE CONTRABAND THE DISCOVERY
AND REMOVE IT PRIOR TO COMING
INTO THE INSTITUTION AS WELL AS
TOOLS THAT WE USE- DETECT AND
FIND CONTRABAND WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. LET ME SEE IF I
DON'T OF FINANCE. AT I'D LIKE
TO ADD THAT THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS THAT CONTRABAND ALSO MAKES
ITS WAY WITHIN THE INSTITUTION-
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
CALLED THAT DROPS WHERE SOMEONE
WILL THROW CONTRABAND OVER THE
FENCE SO INMATES CAN FIND IT.
CONTRABAND ALSO CAN COME IN
THROUGH THE MAIL ROOM SO CDCR
IS STILL ACTIVELY WORKING TO
LOCATE AS MUCH CONTRABAND AS
POSSIBLE SO THERE ARE OTHER
AVENUES OTHER THAN VISITING FOR
THE CONTRAVENTION MAY COULD
STAND SIDE. AND SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
AVENUES FOR THE CONTRABAND BUT
THE STRATEGY IS THAT WERE YOU
SEEN AND- ARE THERE WAYS THAT
WE COULD. YOU STRATEGIES BETTER
OR- ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES WE
COULD BE SEEING I MEAN IT'S
STILL ALMOST TWELVE THOUSAND
CELLPHONES IN TWENTY TWENTY
STILL A REALLY LARGE NUMBER OF
EITHER THROUGH THE MAIL OR
BEING THROWN OVER THE FENCE.
AMOUNTS UHHUH OF CONTRABAND
WE'RE LOOKING AT TOBACCO YOU
KNOW. A FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
POUNDS THIS IS WITH THE SAKE I
REALLY THAT THERE'S MORE THAN
THAT BUT IT JUST SEEMS THAT
MAYBE WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
OUR STRATEGIES FOR THIS
CONTRABAND WHERE INVESTING
MONIES I MEAN I DON'T WANT TO
LAUGH ABOUT THIS WE ARE
INVESTING MONIES- AND DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES ARE TRYING TO DO
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAMS-
AND SO IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT WERE
MAYBE GETTING OUR MONEY'S WORTH
OUT THERE AND SO. I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE A JOKE ABOUT PEOPLE
BRING THINGS OVER THE FENCE BUT
I THINK IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME
POINT WE'VE BEEN- POUNDING ON
FROM THE BEGINNING HAVE YOU
SEEN OUR DAUGHTERS OUR DOLLARS
WISELY OUT THERE AND SO. DO WE
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS OF HOW TO
BETTER USE OUR STRATEGIES ON
THIS CONTRABAND. SO WE HAVE A
REFLECTANCE. WITH HER WOULD WE
HAVE A LARGE- OF THAT COMING IN
THROUGH MAIL ROOM- THREE
PACKAGES- AND ALSO- DROPS
AROUND THE INSTITUTIONS.
HOWEVER RECENTLY AND I'M- ONE
OF OUR PILOT PROGRAM STOP DOWN
OR SAD IF INSTITUTION WE HAD A
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION PILOT
PROGRAM GOING ON FOR A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF- HELP
CSU FRESNO- HAS RECENTLY.
COMPLETED A DRAFT. REPORT ON
THEIR FINDINGS OF OUR PILOT
PROGRAM- WE'RE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THAT DRAFT REPORT AND
ONCE WERE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND INFORMATION- WILL PROBABLY
BE MAKING SOME PROPOSALS ON
SOME. SOME ADDITIONAL-
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES ON ONCE
THEY DETERMINE THAT THEY
RECOGNIZED AS BEING. BOTH THE
BEST AND KEEPING CONTRABAND OUT
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS. IN
CATCHING IT BEFORE IT CAME AND-
THANK YOU- I DO. WHY LAST THING
ON THE CELL BUT BEFORE COVAY ON
THIS IS ACCOUNT I KNOW A LOT OF
HAS PUT VISITORS OUT THERE AND
THIS MOMENTS GIVING US AN
UNWANTED DATA POINT BUT AN
IMPORTANT THAT A POINT THAT
IT'S MORE THAN THAT AND SO I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO THE PROPOSAL
COMING FROM ONE OF OUR GREAT
STATE INSTITUTIONS- TO
HOPEFULLY IMPROVE. THE SYSTEM
SO THAT AS WE ARE INVESTING
AND- HELPING FOLKS WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE I WILL BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL ON AND NOT BEING
DERAILED WITH AND MARCH AMOUNT
OF CONTRABAND COMING IN TO OUR
PRESENCE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COLLEAGUES.
MISTER CHANG. I JUST WANNA FOR
CHAIRS BECAUSE SO SUGGEST
REITERATE IF YOU TO SEE VERY-
GIVEN THE NUMBER. THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY IT ABSOLUTELY WAS
NOT THE VISITORS. IN SO JUST
GOING BACK TO- THAT. MOMENTUM
TO BE SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
JUST. CAN YOU JUST WALK THROUGH
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY THAT-
WERE WERE IMPLEMENTED TO TRY TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF CONTRABAND
COMING INTO THE- FACILITIES.
HERE I'M SORRY COULD YOU HER
LARGER THE QUESTION. NO I GET I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE TALKING TO
ME I'M SORRY- RIGHT RIGHT THE
STATE- SO WE HAVE A PILOT
PROGRAM GOING ON IT'S OUT OF
WHICH YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE OF-
WHERE THEY HAD MANY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES THAT THEY WERE
USING. THEY HAD A TSA'S STYLE-
THE SCANNER LIKE YOU WOULD USE
IN A BAGGAGE PERSONAL SCANNER
ALL THE STAFF AROUND ALL THE
BETTER THINGS THROUGH WE HAD
ENHANCED OR CANINES- WE HAD.
DEPLOYED SOME BONO'S BODY
SCANNERS THERE ARE
INSTITUTIONS- ADDITIONAL
BAGGAGE AND PERSONAL SCANNERS
WE DEPLOYED HIGH SENSITIVITY
METAL DETECTORS- SO WALK
THROUGH METAL DETECTORS AS WELL
SOME COOPER SECURITY CAMERAS
AND ADDITION TO SOME CELLPHONE
FRIEND SIX- MACHINES THAT HELP-
IDENTIFY INFORMATION ON CELL
PHONES. AND WE ALSO DO ENHANCE
OUR SHIP SEARCHES EACH MONTH OR
IN IDENTIFIED AREAS- LOOKING
FOR CONTRABAND I'M TRYING TO-
INTERDICTED BEFORE COMES IN FOR
INSTITUTIONS AND THOSE ARE THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES FOR
EXAMPLE MINUTES SO FAR- AND I'M
PROBABLY MISSING A FEW BUT
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
COMING RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD. NO PRESSURE THAT THESE
GIVE A GUESS AS TO WHY IT SEEMS
THAT- 420-182-2019 THINGS-
WE'RE IMPROVING AND THEN- SOME
OF SOME AREAS SHOWN- SORT AN
UPTICK IN TWENTY TWO DO YOU
HAVE A- ANY. GAS OR- THEORY AS
TO WHY THAT WHY THAT IS BUT
SHE'D GIVEN THAT YOU HAD A LOT
FEWER MOVEMENT OF INMATES AS
WELL AS THE VISITATIONS WERE
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN. I'M THE
QUESTION ON WHY WE THINK WE HAD
MORE OF AN UPTICK- A LOT OF IT
IS LAND DEMAND BY THE END.
RELATION BUT AS WELL AS THE-
AND IT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE- YOU KNOW. ONLY STAFF
WERE COMING AND FOR MANY MANY
MONTHS AND- WE HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB AT- COMING UP WITH
STRATEGIES TO STOP IT BEFORE IT
COMES. IN AND WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT. GOOD GOD SO YOU- I GUESS
WHEN YOU SAY IS THE- PLY VERSES
DEMAND I THINK WE'RE JUST
FOCUSED ON THIS THE PLIGHT PART
WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S DEMAND.
SO- WHY YEAH YES SO I MEAN I
MEAN YOU HAD THE SAY I ASSUME
YOU DIDN'T DO LESS IN. TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO WHAT HAPPENED IN
TOWARD ME MEETING YOU DIDN'T
STOP IN THE- PROCEDURES IN
TWENTY TWENTY DID YOU. IT IS IT
IS IT JUST THE PART THAT YOU
FELT DID YOU FEEL THE
FACILITIES HAD DID A BIT OF A
LESS WORSE JOB OF IMPLEMENTING.
YES YOUR PROCEDURES. NO I DON'T
THINK SO- I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT
THE- PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
PRISON THEY CELEBRATED FAIRLY
GOOD JOB AND INTERDICTING
CONTRABAND- BECAUSE IT WAS A
LARGE REDUCTION IN PEOPLE-
ACROSS THE BOARD COMING INTO
OUR INSTITUTIONS FROM
VOLUNTEERS TO VISITORS- SO
FINDING- THAT MUCH CONTRABAND-
WAS GOOD. THANK YOU THE- OKAY-
EIGHT I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK
TO MISTER TANKS COMMENTS HAVE
YOU LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE
MARIJUANA IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A LOOK AT THE NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
NUMBER WENT DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY
IT WAS CUT IN HALF- BUT THEN WE
SEE THE UPTICK IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
WHAT WHAT WERE YOU DOING MAYBE
BETTER BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN THAT MAYBE WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT WE CAN DO IN TWENTY
TWENTY. NOW WE COULD LOOK AT
THE AMOUNT OF SEARCHES- THAT
WERE DONE- YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT
OF VOLUME- WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MODIFIED PROGRAMS STUDENT HOPE
IT. DOES PEOPLE JUST SEARCH-
LUCKILY WE GET INFORMATION
WE'RE ABLE TO DEPLOY OUR
CANINESAND TO DO MORE TARGETED
SEARCHES IT ON AN ENTIRE
HOUSING UNIT. INSTITUTIONAL
MANDATED TO DO THAT YOU SHOWN
BY. ONCE EVERY EIGHTEEN MONTHS
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE REGULAR
SEARCHES THEY CURRENTLY DO.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S HELPFUL
MAYBE IT THANK YOU SAID YOU'RE
DOING A BETTER JOB SEARCHES
NOW. AND SO MAYBE TAKING SOME
OF THE SKILLS THAT YOU PICKED
UP DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
CALL THERE AND CONTINUE WITH
THAT DOWN THE ROAD OR SOMETHING
THEY COULD ALSO LOOK INTO. I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE. MISA WHERE THAT IS.
THANK YOU SO REGARDING THE SAFE
HOUSING FOR TRANSGENDER
INMATES- SENATOR WIENER'S SB
ONE THIRTY TWO DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE ONGOING FUNDING. SO
ONCE THE INITIAL REGULATIONS
AND PROCEDURES HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN THE IMPLEMENTED WHAT
DOES THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVE THE
POSITIONS WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT WOULD NOT OTHERWISE.
BE ABSORBED BY EXISTING STAFF
RESOURCES. HELLO THIS IS
CAPTAIN STARK. SO- BE ABLE TO
HELP YOU OKAY YEAH GO AHEAD SO
IT IS A PART OF SOME OF THE
POSITIONS REQUESTE ARBOR-
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR TO
SPECIALIST SO THOSE POSITIONS
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD HELP
WITH- CONSISTENCY IN DECISIONS
MADE WHAT IN THE REQUEST TO BE
HOUSE BASED ON THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY SO NOT ONLY WILL THEY
BE PROVIDING TRAINING TO THE
COMPLICATIONS STOP THAT ARE
WORKING OUT OF THOSE PHONES-
CASES OR CALL. THEY WILL ALSO
BE- HANDLING SOME OF THAT WORK
BEHIND THOSE REQUESTS- ALSO.
WHAT WE REALIZED WHEN THE
TRANSGENDER WORKGROUP WAS
ESTABLISHED WAS THE OTHER
AREAS- THAT REALLY NEEDED SOME
ATTENTION- SURROUNDING SB ONE
THIRTY TWO IMPLEMENTATION
THOROUGH MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SO MEDICAL- REQUESTED
YOUR HELP OF A PHYSICIAN
SURGEON POSITION AND MEDICAL I
AM VERY MENTAL HEALTH REQUESTED
I'M A PSYCHIATRIST AND A
PSYCHOLOGIST I BELIEVE- AND
REALLY. THE ONGOING TREATMENT
OF THE ON GOING IN- FEDERATIONS
UP FOR THIS- POPULAR POPULATION
WAS IDENTIFIED VIA THE
WORKGROUP AND- PENCE THE DIRT
ADDITIONAL REQUESTED POSITIONS.
THANK YOU. IF I AM AND MAYBE I
CAN. HEY WE WERE JUST LOOKING
AT THIS IS WRONG TO ME BACK IN.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. CAN HELP AND
THIS IS ALSO. A REASON WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE DATA. AND
MAYBE THE COMMITTEE MIGHT BE.
YOU MAY BE SEEING SOMETHING
THAT WERE NOT SEEN OR NOT
COMMUNICATING WELL. AND LET'S
JUST LOOK AT CELLULAR PHONES.
ELEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THAT WERE
CONFISCATED IN TWENTY TWENTY. I
BELIEVE. YOUR BASEMENT ON
EIGHTEEN INSTITUTIONS AND IT
SAYS THE MANAGE ACCESS SYSTEM
SOLUTION PREVENTS THE CELL FROM
FROM CONNECTING TO CELLULAR
SERVICE EFFECTIVELY
NEUTRALIZING COMMUNICATION
CAPABILITIES INSIDE THE PRISON.
SAUL LET'S JUST SAY. OUT OF
THOSE EIGHTEEN PRISONS ARE WE
BELIEVE EVERY PRISONER AND NOTE
EIGHTEEN PRESENT. HAVE A
CELLULAR PHONE. THIS IS ALL
PRISONS SAWDA NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND SOME ODD PRISONERS YOU
WERE ABLE TO CONFISCATE ELEVEN
THOUSAND HOUSE GOING TO SAY IF
THIS WAS BASED ON EARLY
EIGHTEEN MAYBE TWENTY THOUSAND
YOU GOT 50% OF THEM I WOULD
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO GIVE
EVEN MORE MONEY TO GET RID OF
THE OTHER ELEVEN THOUSAND. BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS OPERATION
MAY NOT BE AS EFFECTIVE AS WE
WITH THAT ARM ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT- THE PEOPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY. ARE ABLE TO
BASICALLY BE FRAUD. THE
TAXPAYERS OF THIS STATE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN EDT FOR
OUR- I WOULD EVEN SAY WE SHOULD
GIVE MORE MONEY TO IT BUT IT I
DON'T KNOW HOW IT EFFECTIVE
THIS STRATEGY IS WHICH MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
RECOMMEND THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH DOING MORE THAT UNLESS WE
HAVE AN AUDIT THAT SHOWS. THAT
IN CERTAIN PRISONS THERE WAS
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE AND SO WHAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE HEARING NOW IS
EVEN IF WE DO THIS WE HAVE TO
DO ADDITIONAL THINGS. BIKE
CAMERAS FOR PRISON GUARDS LIKE
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE. NOT
JUST AS THE CDC- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SECRETARY TOLD ME THAT
ALL THESE PHONES WERE COMING IN
UNDER BRED TRUCKS ESPECIALLY
WITH INSTITUTIONS THAT ACTUALLY
MAKE THEIR BREAD THEY DON'T
HAVE BRED SHIFTED THE INMATES
ARE MAKING THE BREAD. AND SALT
I THINK YOU NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND REALLY LOOK
CLOSELY. IN AMERICA. AND LOOK
AT WAYS THAT YOU CAN STOP. ALL
OF THIS CONTRABAND FROM COMING
IN. AND CREATE SYSTEMS NOT ONLY
WORKED WITH CAMERAS ON EVERY
PRISON GUARD AT A BILL THEN.
BUT YOU ALSO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
YOU YOU. SEND EACH ONE TO SOME
KIND OF SCREENING PROCESS I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN TOLD IT WOULD
BE ADDITIONAL COSTS IN LABOR.
BUT IF YOU DID THE MATH OF THE
NUMBER OF GUARDS EACH DAY TIMES.
THREE AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS AND
HOW MUCH TIME IT TAKES. I'M NOT
SURE YOU WOULD GET TO A BILLION
DOLLARS. IN N. AND COST OVER
TIME OR IN THIS CASE BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO STOP
THE CONTRABAND THE DEATHS THE
SUICIDES THE OVERDOSES THAT ARE
RESULT OF ALL OF IT. AND SO IF
WE WERE TO ACOSTA NOW TO DO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE IF WE WERE
JUST DO A COST ANALYSIS OF IT.
AND YOU WERE TO BRING IT TO US
WAYS YOU COULD YOU PLEASE STOP
CONTRABAND IF YOU BROUGHT A
COMPREHENSIVE- PROPOSAL TO US.
I HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WHERE NOT ONLY
EMBRACE IT- BUT WE WOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. AND
AGAIN I WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S
BEEN ANY ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES ON THIS M. A. S.
SYSTEM- AND SEE HOW EFFECTIVE
IT IS AND- ROOTING OUT CONTRA.
AND SO- BUT I. YOU KNOW I WAS
CORRECTED I THOUGHT IT WAS ONLY
EIGHTEEN INSTITUTIONS HOURS
CORRECTED THAT THAT NUMBER WAS
OVER. ALL OF THE INSTITUTION
MEANS ALL OF THE INMATES AND SO
OXIDES IS STILL I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S OUT OF. YOU KNOW IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND- CELL PHONES THERE
LEGALLY CONTRABAND IN PRISONS.
WELL YEAH ELEVEN THOUSAND IS A
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE NUMBER BUT AS
THE CLOSER TO FIFTY OR SIXTY
THOUSAND THEN YEAH WE'VE WE'VE
GOT A- REDO OUR NUMBERS AND SO
IF YOU COULD. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT OR IF YOU
CAN COME BACK TO US WITH A MORE
ROBUST PLAN ON HOW TO GET RID
OF CONTRABAND. IN PRISONS I
WOULD I WOULD EMBRACE IT LOVE
IT HECK WE WOULD EVEN. FUND.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. HI THIS IS
TAMMY IRWIN AGAIN. I'M I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT IT IT DOES
APPEAR AS THOUGH THE-
INSTITUTIONS WHERE WE HAVE
MANAGED ACCESS TO PLAY DO HAVE.
FEWER CONFISCATION- OF.
CONTRABAND I'M- ALSO. I'M WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
ONCE DEPLOYED ONCE THE
CONTRABAND REACHES INSIDE THE
PRESIDENT OF CONTRABAND.
CELLULAR DEVICES ARE INSIDE THE
PRESIDENT. THAT MANAGE ACCESS
IS THE TECHNOLOGY- THAT HELPS
TO- WORK THROUGH AND THE
DETERRENT OF- BRINGING IN
ADDITIONAL DEVICES ESPECIALLY
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
NEW WARRANT PROCESS. WHERE WE
ARE WRITING A WARRANT TO THEN
DE ACTIVATE DEVICES I
PERMANENTLY SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT WILL URTHER
DETERMINE THAT IS A STILL A
FAIRLY NEW PROCESS I WITH THIS
MANAGED ACCESS SYSTEM AND WE
WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO
CONTINUE. WITH THAT- BUT THAT
PROCESS AND TO FEED BE A DEEPER
IMPACT BUT IT MAY HAVE. CAN I
WOULD BE WAITING TO HEAR THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF IT- IT'S NOT
THE DISK COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR THAT TOO THANK YOU. THE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU KNOW I JUST
ALSO WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT THE MANAGE ACCESS SERVICE
IS TO PREVENT THE CELL FROM
FROM WORKING BUT WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD NOT OVERLOOK IS THAT
WHAT CITIES HERE IS PROPOSING
WHICH IS A VERY GOOD THING IS
DECOUPLING. HOW THEY'RE PAYING
FOR THE MAN'S ACCESS SERVICE
AND IF WE'RE PAYING FOR IT THAT
MEANS THE PRISONERS. THEMSELVES
OF PEOPLE INCARCERATED. WHO
HAVE BEEN PAYING FOR THROUGH
EXORBITANT TELEPHONE FEES. ARE
GOING TO BE PAYING FOR IT AND
SO FOR US TO TAKE THAT. EXPENSE
ON IS GOOD. BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKING AWAY FROM PROBLEM HOW
THAT HAS BEEN FUNDED BUT IT
ALSO GIVES US BETTER INSIGHT
INTO THE COSTS AND DEMANDS THAT
SYSTEM AND I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD SYSTEM AND NEEDS TO BE
EXPLORED. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT THE WAY THAT JAILS AND
PRISONS HAVE BEEN. UTILIZING
AND BENEFITING FROM THE
TELEPHONE SERVICE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN USING THE REVENUES
FROM THAT SERVICE TO FIND A
NUMBER DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WHICH
AGAIN IS JUST THE WRONG WAY
AROUND. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
VISIBILITY AND HOW THOSE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED. AND
THEN THE CONTRCTOR THE
TELEPHONE PROVIDER IS MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY OFF OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE PHONE
CALLS AND THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE PHONE CALLS.
THAT THAT I COULD EVER EVEN
IMAGINE. AND ANTITHETICAL TO
WHAT WE WANT TO BE DOING SO
MANAGING COMMUNICATIONS IN A
BETTER WAY. AND TAKING KIND OF
CONTROL OF WHAT THOSE WHAT IT
HAD BEEN. FUNDED THROUGH THOSE
CONTRACTS IS REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ALSO ABOUT AND THIS IS A
GOOD THING I THINK IS TO SHIFT
HOW THIS EXPENSES HAPPENING
GIVING US BETTER VISIBILITY BUT
THEN ALSO UNDERSTANDING. THAT
TECHNOLOGY BETTER AND HOW THAT
BECOMES A DETERRENT. TO THE USE
OF CELLPHONES BECAUSE AS IF HIS
CELL PHONE IS NO LONGER USABLE
INSIDE. AND THROUGH A SYSTEM
LIKE THIS CAN BE IDENTIFIED. IN
BE SHUT DOWN AND LOCATED THEN
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE USE THE
TECHNOLOGY. SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK THIS IS THIS IS A GOOD
TRACK AND WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT. THE WAYS WE HAVE BANNED
UTILIZING SOME OF THESE
CONTRACTS IN HAD BEEN DONE FOR
FISCAL REASONS. BUT UTILIZE
THESE CONTRACTS N. AND THEN
PASSING ON THE EXPENSES
INAPPROPRIATELY THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED. I THANK YOU
FOR THAT INFORMATION- MISTER
SUN THAT PERSPECTIVE. OKAY SO
JUST WE WERE AGAIN WE WILL BE
TAKING ACTION TODAY- AN EXCITED
ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY DISCUSSION
THAT THIS TOOK PLACE AND JUST
WANTED TO COUPLE UP ON THE-
FROM THE DRUG DISCUSSION SINCE
THEN THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE'RE ALSO SEEING AN INCREASE
GOING ON EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
LESS MOVEMENT UNLESS
VISITATION. AS YOU GUYS ARE
WORKING ON THAT SO I HOPE IN
THE FUTURE I IT AFTER YOUR- GET
THE REPORT FROM. HEALTHY FAST
THOUGH YOU'RE ABLE TO SHARE
WITH THE SOME ADDITIONAL
STRIDES HE'S GOING TO BE USING
TO HELP PREVENT THE CONTRABAND
FROM COMING INTO THE FACILITIES
SO WERE LITTLE BETTER EQUIPPED
TO HELP OUR AND MATES- BE ABLE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THEIR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. HEALTHCARE SO
WITH THAT I'M AND I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON
THE PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT THIS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THE AGENDA AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THE HEARING. THE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE. FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN AGAIN.
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099. 916-319-2099 AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU
WE ALSO ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS WELL. THIS CAN BE
SUBMITTED AT BUDGET SUB FIVE AT
A. S. M. DOT CA DOT GOV AND IS
ALSO LISTED ON THE AGENDA.
PHYLIS SORT OUT THAT WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN THE
ROOM ANYONE WITH SPEAKER IN THE
ROOM PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
LOOKS LIKE WE DO NOT- OPERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN UP ONLINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. EACH PERSON HAS
UP TO ONE MINUTE FOR THEIR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL VIA THE
PHONE IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU A LINE
NUMBERS. WHEN YOU'RE MY
NUMBER'S CALLED. YOUR LINE WILL
BE OPEN. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT BURKE
FIRST COMMENT. I'M NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. NINETY SEVEN. IF
YOU COULD SPEAK UP A LITTLE
LOUDER AND TO THE POINT. BETTER
YES THAT'S BETTER THANK YOU.
PERFECT AWESOME- YEAH THANK YOU
SO MUCH- YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
IT. QUICKLY YEAH ATTENTION I
APPRECIATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS MEETING I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT MORE THAN
ANYTHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE MAY CREATE FOR THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY YOU
ARE. THE MOST IMPACTED THERE
ARE SO. MANY ORGANIZATIONS AND
COALITIONS DEDICATED TO INDYCAR
STAR RATING- L. A. COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA IN GENERAL AND I
THINK THOSE. ORGANIZATIONS NEED
TO HAVE A SEAT AT THIS TABLE
IT'S CLEAR FROM THIS MEETING
ALONE THAT. THE CDC ARE DOESN'T
HAVE. LAN ON HOW TO EFFECTIVELY
KEEP CLOSE WHICH WILL IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND TO DO THE WE NEED
TO HEAR FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS
YOU KNOW THE NEW SUBMIT
ADMINISTRATION SHARE THAT DAY
WANT TO- REDUCE THE STATE.
INCARCERATION FOOTPRINT AND TO
DO THAT WE- NEED COMMUNITY
INPUT MORE THAN EVER- EIGHT
O'CLOCK IN THE TIME OF COKE
LIKE IT'S VITAL THAT WILL BE TO
PRINT CLOSURE JUST UP IN DARK.
MMHM BEHIND THE SCENES. PEOPLE
AND THEY CAN YOU NEED TO THAT
THE VOICE HEARD AND WE NEED TO
KEEP PLANTS CHRISTIAN CLOSURE
REALLY AND THAT THIS WORKS AND
PRETENDS STAY CLOSE THANK YOU.
CAN YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOU HAVE TO BRING UP
THE NEXT BECAUSE- MADAM
OPERATOR. MY NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF YOU COULD STATE
YOUR NAME. OKAY LOCK. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR THEIR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR
DOCTRINAL CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE CALL. HI MY NAME IS MARY
MORENO AND- I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU GUYS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT- I HAVE A HAVE BEEN A
VERY INTERESTING- MEETING- I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT HOW FEW
FACTORS REGARDING- YOU KNOW
THAT DISCUSSION GOING ON HERE-
REGARDING GETTING MORE. BUDGET
FIFTY MILLION TO BE EXACT FOR-
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN THE REAL
DISCUSSION SHOULD BE YOU KNOW
HOW ARE WE GONNA YOU KNOW- PLAN
HOW TO CLOSE OUT ALL THESE
CHRISTIANS AND I THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A TOP
REGARDING- ASSEMBLY GETTING
BUDGET. YOU KNOW TO PREPARE THE
STAFF. FOR THE CLOSURE OF THESE
PRISONS AND TO HAVE THEM YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE THAT THEY STILL
HAVE BECAUSE THIS IS THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE A
TOP AROUND BACK. ALSO AS FAR AS
THE CELLPHONE OF THE CONTRABAND
I DON'T THINK. YOU KNOW IT HAS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AND WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR. JUST BEING
LIKE A WASTE OF MONEY- WE
SHOULD BE ACTUALLY MOVING
TOWARDS ACTUALLY GIVING-
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FELL.
BECAUSE ACT FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT
NOW YOU KNOW DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE
DEFINITELY KEPT THEM IN CONTACT
WITH THEIR LOVED. ONES AND THAT
IS VERY MUCH NEEDED- OTHER THAN
THAT- I JUST FEEL LIKE THE FOOD
IT ON THE SITUATION. REALLY
HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED. BECAUSE
TO MY UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE RECEIVED- BUDGET IN
THE PAST. TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF THE FOOD. AND HENCE
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IS THAT THEY
DECIDED TO TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO- YOU KNOW MAKE
THEIR OWN FOOD TO THAT P. I. H.
AND- HAVE BEEN PULLED BACK.
IT'S COULD NOT EDIBLE- AND IT'S
DAY OKAY YOU KNOW WE'RE- DO
ABOUT COMMON. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT PERSON PLEASE
FIND ONE. PARDON ME- NINE ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIMPLY
STAVING. HI THIS IS A SHOCKING
FIRST I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
QUESTIONING REGARDING
CONTRABAND SH BUT SURELY THAT
THE TO BE DISCONTINUED IF
YOU'RE STILL HAVING ISSUES THE
QUALITY CLEARLY COMING. AND
AFTER. WE ARE MORE MONEY TRYING
DESPERATELY THEIR OWN
DISTRIBUTION OF CONTRABAND.
THAT PENALIZING THE FAMILY.
CONTACT I WOULD LIKE TO UPLOAD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUMP YOUR
SENTIMENTS AND PVC ARE LACK OF
ACTION. RECENTLY THE SENATE. WE
ARE ABOUT THEIR COURTSHIP
PACKED WATER. VALLEY STATE
PRISON IN. CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL INSTABILITY.
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISONS ARE TRYING TO BE
FORCED TO DRINK AND- IMPACT
THE- TACTIC WATER. BEYOND THE
REACH OF. WE CAN VERY MUCH
PEOPLE IN I THINK. DR MICHAEL
TO CONSIDER THE PUBLIC HOW
IMPACT THE PRISON INCLUDING
TACTIC AND WATER WE BELIEVE
ONLY RESPONSE LETTER TO THE
TECHNICAL SAFETY A GREAT MATCH
FOR THE MARKET IS DOWN WE WITH
THE L. A. R. AT THE STATE. HIRE
TIED THE CLOSURE MORE THE
TROOPER NICK YEAR I BELIEVE THE
STATE SHOULD FOCUS ON TEMP
MOVEMENT EXCITING. WE INVEST
TIME THAT WE SPENDING IN
COMMITTED SHOULD ADMINISTRATION
O'MALLEY OVER CLOSING FIVE.
EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NOT COCKINESS TENTH
ABILITY AND REPAIRS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. EDT ARE. WE
ARE ASKING THE SPEAKER SO
PLEASE LIMIT THE FOR TO ONE
MINUTE. NINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. MY
NAME IS ALAN CASEY AND I HAVE
TO SAY THE ASKING OF COLLUDED
TO ONE MINUTE WHEN. THIS
MEETING WAS OVER AN HOUR LATE
GETTING STARTED AND WE HAVE
BEEN SITTING LISTENING TO YOU
TALK FOR OVER TWO HOURS IS
INSANE. ALLIES TO MY PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND PROJECT MANAGER
MEANS THAT CLOSED PRISON STATE
COURT PRISON POPULATIONS ARE
REDUCED TO THE MISSION IS NOT
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER ON TAKE
THE THIRTIES. CORRECTIONS
BUDGETS ARE SLASHED INVESTMENT
IN RE ENTRY AND OTHER SERVICES
ARE PRIORITISED. MOISTURE OF
JUSTICE IMPACTED PEOPLE ARE
HEARD AND THAT LABOR SOLUTIONS
FOR DISPLACED PERSONS THAT
STAFF ARE FROT AND CENTER.
WHEN IMPLEMENTING NAFTA LEASES
AND PRISON CLOSURES SAFEGUARDS
MUST BE IN PLACE TO PREVENT THE
TRANSCRIPT OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO ICE
CUSTODY. BUT NOT FORGET. DURING
DURING NEED FOR RECKONING ON
RACIAL INJUSTICE. THAT MEANS
NOT ONLY DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING PRISON RELEASES BUT
CHANGING TOUGH ON CRIME WATER
POLICING POLICIES. THAT HAD
BEEN DRIVING INCARCERATION
CRISIS. BY FILLING THE STATE
ANTI PRISON BEDS AND
REINFORCING A TOXIC CULTURE-
BUT ACTUAL PUNISHMENT. WE NEED
A PEOPLE'S PLAN FOR PRISON
CLOSURE BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
THE GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS DON'T
BE SAVING LIVES AND BILLIONS.
OF DOLLARS ARE THE PRIORITY.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS A AND PLEASE TAKE
YOUR NAME. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. MINING DAMAGED OFFENSIVE
GUARD I'M CALLING OKAY. IT'S
AFFECTED A LOT OF WHAT EVERYONE
HAS TRIED AND JUST SAY THAT I
HOPE THAT WHEN WE'RE CLOSE
ENOUGH PRISONS THAT. THE
RELEASE OF MORE PEOPLE RATHER
THAN TRANSFERRING THEM IN. I'M
TRYING TO SO BAD. AND ALSO JUST
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO. DID NOT
INVOLVE A LOT MORE INTIMACY I
PRESUME- BUT RATHER INVEST MORE
IN IN THE COMMUNITY AND I WOULD.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. WE'LL GIVE IT
ONE SECOND. CAPABILITY TO THE
CONTAMINANTS PUSH TO COME. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON THEPHONE. DO YOU
HAVE ANOTHER COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE. GO AHEAD. THE MOMENT
MOTHER LINE NUMBERS GATHERED.
IN ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. HI MY NAME IS
ALAN DAVIDSON I'M GOING TO MAKE
A QUICK COMMENT AND JUST SAY
THAT WE NEED TO STOP SPENDING
MONEY AND ALLOWING BBC ARE
COULD GET AWAY WITH THAT BUT
THERE IS A WHOLE MEETING WE
CONSTANTLY THOUGHT THE SAME
PATTERNS THAT THEY CANNOT SHOW
YOU THE STUFF THAT THEY NEED TO
SHOW ACT AS YOUR CONTENT. YOU
GET THEIR CONTENTS WHAT WE
DESERVE AND EARNED THE RIGHT TO
BE HERE FOR MORE THAN ONE EVENT
I'M NOT GONNA TRY BENEFIT CHEN
MINUTE THAT WOULD NOT BE FREE
LIKE THAT EITHER BUT YOU REALLY
ARE USING FOR THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY ARE
REALLY IMPACTED. BY
INCARCERATION. THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT GOING TO GET THE OUT
OF WHAT HE WANT AND THEN RAN I
WON TO TALK ABOUT THE COUNTRY
BACK. THEY ONLY WANT TO BLAME
SOMEBODY. FROM AND YOU GUYS TO
GET FOR YOUR SPOUSE. ASKED IF
BILL GOING ON AND THEY'RE GOING
TRY EVERY USED IN THE BOOK. BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THEY
NOT BEING THERE COURSE OFFICERS.
FOR THE COUNTRY BACK COMING IN
STATE PRISONS NO THAT. REMEMBER
WHY THE IF THEY COULD MENTAL
WORK THERE ARE. A FOR WHEN YOU
BACK DURING A PANDEMIC AND
PUMPING THEIR THERE'S- WHILE
GOING IN TO. WORK ONE THING
BEING THAT THEY'RE CHECKING BAG
AND. AND BACKPACK THE BILL
NUMBER BRINGING IT. THANK YOU
BYE. OKAY THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHT FOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND CLICK STATE YOUR
NAME. GOOD EVENING MADAM SHARED
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ED LITTLE
MAN WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CLOSURE
OF BDI AND WANT TO PUSH FOR THE
CLOSURE OF ADDITIONAL PRISONS.
IN OUR TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT.
KIND OF SAFE AND SOUND HE
CALLED FOR THE CLOSURE OF FIVE
HUNDRED. AND REALLOCATION OF
STAVING SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH
AS REENTRY HOUSING. ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SUPPORTS AS
WELL AS INCREASED SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS OF CRIME. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THE CLOSURE OF BVI
IN OTHER PRISONS AS WELL AS
REINVESTING SAVINGS IN A SHARED
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. THANK YOU AT THE END
J. CAME. I WANT TO SPEAK ON THE
CLOTHING- THANK. WE NEED A
PEOPLE PLAN TO PREVENT CLOSURE
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE A
PROFESSIONAL DON'T YOU EIGHTY
FIVE. DOLLARS A PRIORITY IN
HOUSTON ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
PARTNER THE COMMUNITY CREATE A
PLAN FOR CRITICAL HERE BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE NOT COMPACTED BY A
CORPORATION. OUR BEST
PREDICTION. FROM PARTY THAT
WORK. IF YOU I THINK THAT THERE
CAN. ON KNOWN TO CALL. TO
CLOSE. AND WE KNOW. WHAT WE
KNOW IT DECREASING. HOW WILL
PROTECT WHO CALL THE NINETEENTH
IS GOING TO DEATHS CAR THREE
PEOPLE. ARE CRITICAL KERR BY
CONSULTING TO THE TO READ.
EIGHT BACK THE GENERAL. WE ARE
A LOT NEARLY TWENTY. THOUSAND
PEOPLE L. A. COUNTY WHY WOULD
WE AND FORTY THOUSAND IN THE
STATE WHY ARE WE ALLOWING ANY
MORE. YEAH WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW. WE DON'T
KNOW THE FATE CANNOT. NEEDS
WAIT FILLING THE PUMP BILLION
UNTIL PERSONS ARE. APPLICATOR
MONEY AND FOR THAT SHE. THE
PARKING CULTURE MUSICAL CIRCUIT
BAKER. AND PRISON POPULATION
ARE REDUCED TO RELEASE NOT
TRANSFER OTHER THINK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. I THINK
CORPORATIST TO THEIR ME THIS
HOUR ADJOURNED.